Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Britlaff und hier ist Ausgabe Nummer, was haben wir denn eigentlich, 138.
Ist jetzt dran, genau. Und nachdem es hier zuletzt mal nicht um die Ukraine
ging, sondern um Serbien und ich mit Dian da ein Update gemacht habe zu der Situation dort vor Ort,
kehren wir wieder zur Ukraine als Thema zurück und begrüße dazu erst natürlich erstmal Pavel.
Hallo.
Genau, 135 war die Sendung, die sich zuletzt konkret mit der Ukraine auseinandergesetzt hat,
ausgerechnet Alaska, haben wir die Sendung genannt, weil da stand dieses Trump-Putin-Treffen
unmittelbar bevor, wo wir vorhergesagt haben, dass da nichts bei rauskommt.
Und wie lagen wir damit so in etwa, Pavel?
Ja, ich glaube, wir hatten recht.
Genau, also da kam wirklich gar nichts bei raus. Aber es gibt viele andere interessante
politische und auch militärische Entwicklungen und darüber wollen wir euch natürlich
aufklären. Letzte Sendung war vom 16.
August, also da haben wir sie veröffentlicht. Mit anderen Worten,
es sind jetzt auch schon wieder sechs Wochen ins Land gegangen.
Und ich muss sagen, das waren schon wieder so sechs Wochen, wo ich mir dachte
so, ah, war ja, war ja, war ja, es passiert schon wieder so viel,
es gibt schon wieder so viele neue Aspekte.
Jetzt müssen wir das aber echt mal wieder zusammenfegen.
Manchmal ist es gar nicht so einfach, immer wenn man das Gefühl hat,
so jetzt wäre es mal an der Zeit, dann klappt es halt gerade irgendwie nicht,
weil was anderes dazwischen gekommen ist.
Naja, aber ich glaube, wir kriegen es jetzt noch ganz gut eingefangen und haben
eine interessante Sendung für euch vorbereitet.
Wir fangen an, wie immer, mit der militärischen Entwicklung,
also was sich jetzt eigentlich konkret on the Battleground so getan hat.
Das mag immer so ein bisschen kriegsfixiert wirken, aber ich denke,
es ist schon ganz wichtig, da einfach mal die Realität kurz zu fassen.
Um einfach auch ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was passiert da eigentlich wirklich?
Ich hatte auch viel Diskussion mit Leuten in den letzten Wochen,
also jetzt über den Krieg an sich.
Und auch Menschen, die normalerweise, würde ich sagen, sich ganz gut informiert
fühlen, kriegen eigentlich so über unsere Medien von dieser Ist-Situation immer
relativ wenig mit. Also das ist so mein Eindruck.
Und das mag viel damit zu tun haben, dass wir fast keine Auslandsreporter mehr
haben bei den einzelnen Medien. Weder bei den öffentlichen.
Spiegel hat irgendwie auch nur noch sehr wenige. Und das ist einfach so ein generelles Problem.
Und deswegen kriegen wir ja einfach sehr viel Second-Hand-Nachrichten.
Agenturmeldungen, was CNN gesagt hat und so weiter. Also es wird einfach zu
viel oder zu wenig auf sich selbst geguckt und zu wenig in die Außenbeobachtung geschaut.
Na gut, aber gucken wir erstmal, was jetzt wirklich passiert ist.
Wir hatten in der letzten Sendung erwähnt, dass es einen Vorstoß der Russen
gab, der da gerade viel Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt hat und der dann nämlich auch wieder so,
daran merkt man das eigentlich immer, was ist jetzt schon wieder passiert,
denke ich mir dann so, wenn das dann so in der Tagesschau kommt und dann kommt
es irgendwie auch beim Spiegel und hier und da und alle berichten auf einmal darüber so.
Ja, Russen auf dem Vormarsch.
Was, habe ich irgendwas nicht mitbekommen?
Und dann war das Ganze ja ein, naja, Durchbruch ist ein großes Wort.
Den Russen ist es gelungen, an einer Stelle in der Nähe von Pukrovsk so 10,
20 Kilometer innerhalb kürzerer Zeit voranzuschreiten.
Und das klingt natürlich dann immer erstmal so wie ein massiver Durchbruch.
War es in gewisser Hinsicht auch, weil dort halt dann Stellungen erreicht wurden,
die die Ukrainer vorbereitet hatten, so als Rückfalllinie.
Das heißt, dann saßen dann auf einmal russische Soldaten da in den Bunkern,
die sich die Ukraine eigentlich für sich gebaut hatten.
Aber das war halt jetzt nicht, dass da irgendwie so Horden von zehntausenden
Soldaten übers Land gehen, sondern das waren halt ganz kleine Stoßtruppen nach
dieser neuesten russischen Taktik,
wo dann mal so hier zwei und da mal vier und regelmäßig werden so kleinere Gruppen
einfach losgeschickt, so nach dem Motto,
ja seht mal wie weit ihr kommt, bevor ihr umgebracht werdet und da dieser Frontverlauf
generell einfach kein Frontverlauf ist, wie wir das vielleicht noch so vom ersten
oder zweiten Weltkrieg im Kopf haben oder wie man sich das generell so vorstellt,
dass da so die Frontlinie ist und alle zehn Meter steht da ein Soldat und passt
auf, dass nichts passiert,
haben wir es hier mit einem sehr
viel ausgedünnteren und sehr viel technologisierten Frontverlauf zu tun.
Das heißt, nicht überall sind jetzt irgendwelche Truppen, sondern es sind teilweise
auch nur sehr kleine Gruppen, die dann auch einfach mal ein Gebiet von mehreren
Kilometern überblicken, das aber dann alles mit Drohnen überwachen.
Und natürlich kann es sein, dass trotz dieser permanenten Drohnenüberwachung
hier und da sich mal jemand durchsneakt.
Und das ist an dieser Stelle passiert. Da war es dann wahrscheinlich doch ein bisschen zu dünn.
Aber diese Situation ist mittlerweile auch schon wieder eingefangen worden.
Also nachdem dann klar war, dass hier den Russen tatsächlich so ein schmaler
Korridor gelungen ist, der relativ tief in ukrainisch kontrolliertes Gebiet eingefallen ist,
haben sie dort dann Truppenverstärkung vorgenommen und auch einen echten Gegenangriff gemacht.
Der dann aktuell so ist, dass halt größere Teile dieser Truppen,
die dort eingefallen sind,
mittlerweile abgeschnitten sind vom Rest und dort gerade ausharren und letztlich
so von den Ukrainern ausgehungert werden.
Sie meinen halt so, die haben halt irgendwie die Möglichkeit sich zu ergeben
oder zu verhungern oder sich erschießen zu lassen.
Ja, was ich erstaunlich fand, war, dass diese Situation, also Einkesselungssituation,
dass die jetzt mehrere Wochen bereits andauert.
So normalerweise denken, okay, so ein Kessel wird dann relativ schnell,
also ein kleiner Kessel, dann,
ja, löst sich irgendwie auf oder entweder, ja,
gelingt den eigenen Truppen, dann den Kessel zu erreichen und dann die Leute
da rauszubringen, aber das ist.
In dem Fall schien jetzt seit Wochen irgendwie statisch zu sein und meine Erklärung ist,
dass, wie du schon richtig sagst, es gibt halt keine klar definierte Frontlinie,
so nach dem Motto irgendwie hier dieser Weg oder diese Straße oder keine Ahnung
dieser Zaun ist jetzt die Front, sondern es gibt eben dieses große Niemandsland,
das sich dann teilweise über 10, 20, 30 Kilometer erstrecken kann.
Wo innerhalb dieses Niemandslands dann Truppen sich verstecken und zwar von
beiden Seiten aus, Weil in diesem Bereich eben alles,
was sich bewegt oder gesehen wird oder ungeschützt ist,
dann von Drohnen verfolgt und angegriffen wird.
Und auch die Versorgung dann dieser Truppen, die da in diesem Bereich sind,
findet dann teilweise eben auch nur per Drohnen statt oder auf andere Art und Weise.
Also das heißt, ja,
es ist halt ein komplettes Katz-und-Maus-Spiel in der Gegend und deswegen scheint
dieser Kessel in dem Sinne auch zu bestehen,
weil er ist relativ klein und wird vermutlich aus der Luft versorgt.
Und ja, es ist also eine Art und Weise, Krieg zu führen, wie wir sie vorher,
glaube ich, noch nicht gesehen haben, sondern höchstens vielleicht in irgendwelchen Science Fiction.
Genau, also im Prinzip ein interessantes Beispiel,
wie anders dort die Dynamiken verlaufen und gerade diese Versorgung mit Drohnen,
also alles läuft mit Drohnen, Überwachung läuft mit Drohnen,
Angriffe laufen mit Drohnen, aber eben auch die Versorgung und teilweise was
Bodendrohnen betrifft halt auch schon die Evakuierung etc.
Es gab da ein interessantes Statement von einem Ausbilder, der dort in der Ukraine
an der Front auch tätig ist, also ein Amerikaner,
der Ex-Special Forces Anhänger, der die Situation dann nur so kommentierte.
Also meine ehemalige Special Forces Einheit mit der Ausbildung von damals würde
irgendwie keine zwei Tage an dieser Front überleben mit dem Wissen und dem Know-how,
weil alles irgendwie anders sei.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich so für alle Forces des Wissens derzeit.
Ja.
Ja, da jetzt auch die Matsch-Saison wieder begonnen hat in der Ukraine,
also zur Erinnerung, das ist immer relativ vorhersehbar,
so gegen Herbst beginnen dann relativ stark Regenfälle und durch die Art und
Weise, wie der Boden ist in der Ukraine, eigentlich ein sehr fruchtbarer Boden,
verschlampt dann die ganze Gegend und so Vorstöße mit größerem Gerät.
Ist dann sehr schwierig. Also
auch mit Panzern. Panzer kommen sowieso nicht mehr so oft zum Einsatz.
Erstmal hat Russland nicht mehr so viele und die Ukraine hatte eh noch nie viele.
Die Verluste sind halt da extrem groß, weil in diesem Drohnenkrieg diese Geräte
einfach zu vulnerable sind.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt mal auch festhalten, diese Sommeroffensive,
wo Russland ja große Ziele hatte, jetzt irgendwie ganz Donetsk einzunehmen,
ist insgesamt nicht besonders erfolgreich gewesen. Es gehört aber auch zur Wahrheit
zu sagen, dass es schon auf breiter Front eine Menge Geländegewinne gab.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, kommt es darauf an, wie weit man jetzt schaut.
So ein paar tausend Quadratkilometer werden es schon gewesen sein.
Allerdings handelt es sich dabei nahezu ausschließlich um Felder und kleine Dörfer.
Keine wirklich großen Siedlungen.
Trotz alledem sind die zwei größeren Siedlungen recht nahe gekommen.
Nämlich konkret eben das schon mehrfach erwähnte Pokrovsk, was aber noch nicht
eingenommen ist. Da sind die Russen nur relativ nah dran.
Aber seit einem Jahr, oder? Stehen sie vor Pokrovsk mehr oder weniger.
Genau, also das war halt dieser, nachdem Avdivka gefallen ist,
sind sie dann relativ schnell über die Felder dann herangerobbt und da dreht
sich die Sache jetzt schon eine Weile im Kreis und auch wenn sie vielleicht
rein technisch hier und da insgesamt immer noch näher herankommen,
muss man halt auch sehen, dieses näher herankommen bedeutet für die Russen,
dass sie einfach enorme Verluste an Personal haben, also es ist einfach….
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein Schlachtfeld. Da werden einfach die Leute verheizt
und die Ukrainer sind halt in der Lage, im Wesentlichen die Situation eben so zu halten.
Nur immer, wenn es dann zu brenzlig wird, weil der Druck der Russen dann zu groß wird,
dann ist halt die Methode der Ukrainer generell, dann geben wir ihnen noch wieder ein bisschen Land.
Aber wir geben ihnen nicht unsere Leute.
Also es ist eine andere Priorisierung. Und die Russen sagen,
Herr mit dem Land, uns doch egal, wie viele Russen dabei sterben.
Das ist ja so ein Muster, das sehen wir jetzt schon eigentlich seit Anfang des
Krieges und speziell in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Dafür steht zum Beispiel auch jetzt dieser Kampf um Chassifjar.
Chassifjar ist der nächstgrößere Ort hinter Bachmut und der Fight um Bachmut
war ja schon super blutig,
ein Jahr gekämpft, um danach die Stadt komplett platt gemacht zu haben und dann
ging es den Hügel hoch, um dann irgendwie Chassifjar einzunehmen.
Das scheint ihnen jetzt so zu 90 Prozent gelungen zu sein.
Das ist nicht gut, aber leitet nicht das Ende des Krieges ein,
zeigt aber eben, wie groß der Aufwand es in Russland vornehmen muss,
um überhaupt irgendetwas Zählbares zu haben.
Und das ist insgesamt natürlich zu wenig für Russland und naja,
wir werden uns jetzt noch mehrfach mit der Gesamtsituation der Russen jetzt auseinandersetzen.
Wir klappern bloß vorher mal noch so die nennenswerten Dinge ab.
Und es gibt auch einzelne Erfolge für die Russen.
Was ein bisschen peinlich war für die Ukraine ist, dass wohl auch die Russen
jetzt so eine Marine-Drone eingesetzt haben.
Also die bauen natürlich dann auch alles nach, was die Ukrainer so an Innovationen
aufs Feld führen. Und offensichtlich ist es den Russen gelungen,
so ein fernsteuerbares Boot mit Sprengstoff auf den Weg zu bringen.
Und irgendwie ist es der Ukraine nicht gelungen, das zu detektieren.
Und die ist dann halt übers Schwarze Meer in die Donaumündung rein.
Das ist ja da die Stelle, wo die Ukraine an Rumänien grenzt.
Und dort gibt es diesen Flussverlauf.
Da gibt es auch ein, zwei Häfen, die relativ wichtig sind. Wir sind auch nicht
so super groß von der Ukraine.
Und dort befand sich so ein Aufklärungsschiff, so ein Abhörschiff.
Keine Ahnung, was da genau für eine Technik drauf ist. Simferopol hieß die.
Und die ist halt von dieser Drohne letzten Endes getroffen worden und versenkt worden.
So 30 Kilometer landeinwärts, das ist schon ein bisschen bitter.
So etwas will man eigentlich nicht sehen, zumal es ja generell so ist,
dass die Ukraine eigentlich der klare Gewinner ist, was den Kampf ums Schwarze Meer angeht.
Also da hat Russland ja eigentlich relativ wenig zu melden.
Die versuchen natürlich jetzt auch mit Drohnen und entsprechenden Gegenmaßnahmen
hier in irgendeiner Form das Blatt zu wenden, aber davon sind sie,
glaube ich, noch sehr weit,
entfernt und riskieren halt derzeit einfach eher die Zerstörung ihrer kompletten
Navy, wenn sie da jetzt mit größeren Schiffen losgehen sollten.
Deswegen findet derzeit alles auch eher so im Drohnenbereich statt und würde
mich nicht wundern, wenn das jetzt noch länger geht, dass wir da dann eben so
einen richtigen Marine-Drone-War sehen, wo definitiv aber auch die Ukraine weiter vorne ist.
Aber alle Ideen, die Ukraine hat, klauen sich dann die Russen halt auch irgendwie,
die werden es zumindest probieren und das ist offen, wie das ausgeht.
Ja, ansonsten haben sie aber eher so Probleme.
Gibt auch lustige Beobachtungen, dass also nachdem sie ja schon Esel einsetzen,
so als Transport in Anführungsstrichen Fahrzeuge, gibt es jetzt wohl auch schon
irgendwie Pferde an der Front.
Make Cavalry great again oder so. Also das ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Man muss halt auch sehen, abgesehen davon, dass tausende Panzer zerstört wurden,
sind laut offiziellen Zählungen schon über 63.000 russische Fahrzeuge aller Art zerstört worden.
Also Trucks und gepanzerte Fahrzeuge und alles mögliche.
Da sind sie teilweise wirklich mit zivilen Fahrzeugen unterwegs und jetzt in
zunehmendem Maße mit Motorrädern.
Und insofern wundert es mich gar nicht, dass sie jetzt dann irgendwie auch noch
auf Pferde zurückgreifen, so schlimm das für die Pferde dann auch ist.
Und generell gibt es einfach in letzter Zeit auch immer mehr Berichte,
dass die russischen Soldaten an der Front einfach langsam durchdrehen.
Also ich meine, wer kann es ihnen verdenken?
Viele sind dort hingelockt worden mit dem Versprechen so, ja,
hier super Bezahlung, Ukraine, drei Monate, passt schon, dann bist du wieder
zurück und glücklich und viele haben das halt gemacht.
Da haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach drüber berichtet, dass die dann einfach
nicht wieder zurückgelassen werden.
Die werden dann einfach bedroht und gezwungen, was weiß ich,
einen offiziellen Vertrag zu unterschreiben, dass sie halt nochmal ein Jahr
dranhängen oder was weiß ich, beziehungsweise es wird halt auch einfach vom
Militär so verfügt, so nach dem Motto, ja,
interessiert uns ja nicht, was jetzt hier auf einem Stück Papier zählt,
bis jetzt hier irgendwie um Russland zu verteidigen, das machen wir jetzt so
lange, bis wir gewonnen haben.
Dann sind sie da teilweise drei Jahre schon vor Ort.
Kein Wunder, dass die anfangen total durchzudrehen, weil die haben ja auch gar keine Informationen.
Also ich meine schon die Russen in Russland sind ja sozusagen weitgehend von
guten Informationen abgeschnitten.
Das ist bei den Soldaten natürlich noch viel schlimmer. Die laufen da rum und
wissen halt überhaupt nicht,
was um sie herum passiert, glauben natürlich dann irgendwie auch alles und in
zunehmendem Maße machen auch noch jetzt die Würsten Verschwörungstheorien die
Runde nach dem Motto, ja wir sollen hier alle umgebracht werden vom russischen Staat,
damit dann irgendwie irgendwelche Migranten unsere Frauen nehmen und so ein Kram.
Also es widerspricht natürlich auch alles irgendeiner Logik,
wie das eben so ist mit Verschwörungstheorien,
aber das scheint so weit verbreitet zu sein, dass einfach dadurch auch schon
nochmal so eine zusätzliche Unruhe entsteht und nichts davon ist in irgendeiner Form gut für Putin.
Das fand ich auch faszinierend, dass die Great Replacement Theory,
die ja normalerweise eher so geht,
dass die Einwanderer aus irgendwelchen anderen Ländern den deutschen oder den
westlichen Mann ersetzen sollen.
Das ist ja üblicherweise das, was so gerne in rechten Kreisen propagiert wird,
dass die Russen das jetzt adaptiert haben,
dass jetzt genau der russische Mann in der Ukraine abgeschlachtet werden soll,
damit dann irgendwelche Mongolenhorden Russland übernehmen können und die russischen
Frauen und weiß ich nicht.
Schon irre.
Nachvollziehbar. Die Leute sind nicht zu beneiden.
Plus natürlich die ganzen drakonischen Strafen, die halt auch weitergehen.
Also massive Körperstrafen und Folter und bis hin zu Erschießungen der eigenen
Leute an der Front. Und das geht also...
Auch weiter. Nicht, dass das überall so ist, aber es kommen nach wie vor eben
Nachrichten und Filme, teilweise von Russen,
selber aufgenommen über solche Gewalttaten in der eigenen Truppe.
Und dementsprechend hoch.
Natürlich ist auch die Selbstmordrate unter russischen Truppen.
Korruption ist massiv.
Hilfsgüter werden gestohlen und, und, und.
Also, ja, jeder versucht irgendwie auch zu überleben oder Geld zu machen oder beides.
Keine Gnade für gar nichts.
Ja, was macht also jetzt die Ukraine?
Die Ukraine, abgesehen davon, dass sie natürlich weiterhin versuchen an der
Front einfach dagegen zu halten und die Russen auf Distanz zu halten,
hat ein paar interessante Strategiewechsel vorgenommen, die sich teilweise schon
bei unserer letzten Sendung, glaube ich, abgezeichnet haben.
Aber mittlerweile wird klar, dass das jetzt so im Mittelpunkt steht,
nämlich die Zerstörung der russischen Infrastruktur.
Und das im Bereich der wirtschaftlichen Infrastruktur, die also für Russland
wirtschaftlich relevant ist,
als auch die logistische Infrastruktur, die also vor allem für die Militärlogistik wichtig ist.
Und das bedeutet, sie greifen Ölraffinerien an, sie greifen Tanklager,
Öllager an oder Benzinlager an.
Sie greifen Ölpipelines, Pumpstationen an und sie greifen auch Verladeterminals,
also die Stellen, wo jetzt wirklich
Öl oder raffinierter Sprit ins Ausland verkauft und weggeschippt wird,
greifen die an, bei St. Petersburg zum Beispiel.
Verladen wird auf Schiffe oder Züge.
Das heißt, das sind jetzt sozusagen die primären Ziele und das ist jetzt nicht
so, dass sie so ab und zu mal irgendwie hier und da mal einer Raffinerie einen Klaps geben,
sondern mittlerweile kannst du schon die Uhr danach stellen,
dass eigentlich jede Nacht irgendeine große Attacke gegen eine oder mehrere Raffinerien läuft.
Wahrscheinlich laufen generell immer mehrere, inwiefern bei einer Attacke vielleicht
wirklich mal alle Drohnen, die da losgeschickt werden, abgeschossen werden.
Das wissen wir natürlich nicht.
Wir sehen im Prinzip immer nur die Ergebnisse, wenn es Berichte gibt.
Das sind dann häufig einfach normale zivile Russen, die sich denken, was ist denn hier los?
Kamera, zack, bumm, posten auf was auch immer für ein Netzwerk.
Und davon bekommt man dann eben diese Bilder oder es gibt halt auch einfach
nur Berichte, aber oft gibt es eben auch Bilder.
Ja und das ist Hardcore. Also es gibt jetzt mittlerweile schöne Maps,
wo sozusagen alle großen Raffinerien Russlands aufgelistet sind und welche davon
wie oft schon getroffen worden sind.
Und ich sage mal so, das sieht nicht gut aus für Russland. Also es ist nahezu
jede größere Raffinerie,
die in dem derzeitigen Drohneneinzugsgebiet, also ungefähr so 1200 Kilometer
der Ukraine liegt, ist angegriffen worden.
Manche zweimal, dreimal, manche sogar fünfmal schon.
Und angegriffen heißt, häufig führt es zu großen Explosionen,
zu teilweise tagelang anhaltenden Bränden, also es gab irgendwie eine,
die fünf Tage lang gebrannt hat und vor allem treffen die Drohnen,
wenn sie denn genau treffen, treffen sie die empfindlichsten Stellen.
Also die teuersten, technisch kompliziertesten Kernbereiche der Raffinerien,
nicht nur irgendwelche Lager, die man ja vergleichsweise einfach ersetzen kann,
sondern eben die komplizierte Technologie, die teilweise eben auch mit westlicher
Technik aufgebaut worden ist, die die Russen nicht so ohne weiteres im Replacement haben.
Und die Auswirkungen sind enorm.
Es gibt verschiedene Einschätzungen und das ist alles schwierig zu quantifizieren,
aber man kann schon davon ausgehen, dass mindestens 30 Prozent der Produktionskapazität
im Raffineriebereich Russlands sind derzeit kaputt.
Also bestenfalls funktioniert noch 70 Prozent.
Das ist eine Zahl, die lässt sich jetzt nicht konkret ausrechnen,
die kann auch höher liegen, aber es gibt halt starke Indikatoren,
dass sie stimmt, weil überall auf einmal eine massive Benzinknappheit ausgebrochen ist in Russland.
Also es gibt zahlreiche Berichte und zwar überall in Russland,
mit der Ausnahme Moskau selbstverständlich und St. Petersburg, wo...
Sagen wir mal, das Elend als letztes landet. Wobei es da auch schon Berichte gibt.
Also es beginnt jetzt schon. Aber wir hatten das schon vor zwei Wochen,
hatten wir das so im fernen Osten Russlands, dann ging es irgendwie so krass nur da.
Die Gegend, also alles, was relativ weit weg war von Moskau,
das hatte auf jeden Fall als erstes Probleme und die allergrößten Probleme hat die Krim.
Auf der Krim gibt es im Prinzip überhaupt nichts mehr.
Da ist alles rationiert. Also wenn man überhaupt irgendwas bekommt,
dann kriegt man so maximal 20
Liter und dann auch nur direkt ins Auto und nicht in den Kanister und so.
Und es wird immer schlimmer. Lange Schlangen, viele Autos können einfach gar
nicht mehr fahren, weil einfach kein Benzin da ist.
Das bezieht sich jetzt im Wesentlichen auf Benzin, also auf 92,
95 und 100 Oktaden Varianten.
Es ist noch nicht so hardcore im Bereich Diesel.
Dieselproduktion ist halt, braucht nicht diese.
Aufwendige Raffinerietechnik, kenne mich da nicht sehr gut aus,
vielleicht hast du da noch ein paar Informationen dazu, aber Dieselproduktion,
weil es ja sagen wir mal auch das Wichtigste ist fürs Militär,
das ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Hauptziel ist halt wirklich diese Benzinproduktion, wobei ich mich das nicht
wundern würde, wenn also auch die Dieselproduktion demnächst leiden wird.
Ja, also ein russisches Militär benutzt auch mehr Benzin als Diesel.
Im Vergleich jetzt zum deutschen Militär oder in Deutschland,
wo LKW alle mit Diesel fahren, ist es halt,
ja, wobei gut am Ende viele der Militärmotoren kannst du Diesel als auch Benzin verbrennen.
Da kannst du alles reinkippen im Prinzip, was irgendwie brennt.
Was geht?
Ja, Alkohol, also Rasierwasser.
Ja, weil so ein Selbstzünder ist doch eine ganz andere Geschichte als Zündkerzen.
Ja,
trotzdem geht.
Wodka, ja?
Ja, hochkonzentrierten Wodka. Tja, also, nee, nee, das, aber gut,
normalerweise, wie gesagt,
eher Benzin, auch beim Militär als Diesel.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, the horror is real und entweder gibt es halt gar keinen
Sprit oder der Sprit ist mittlerweile schon 50% teurer.
Im Vergleich zu Deutschland ist das natürlich immer noch relativ billig.
Ja klar, das ist natürlich auch immer schon so einer der Gewinne gewesen.
Meine Russen haben natürlich auch sehr viel weniger Kaufkraft,
von daher ist diese 50-prozentige Kostensteigerung schon enorm.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht ausgerechnet, ich glaube die Preise sind so ungefähr
bei 100 Rubel das würde bedeuten, dass es so ungefähr,
1 Euro pro Liter ist und das für die Russen relativ viel, es war halt vorher so eher so bei 70 Rubel.
Also entsprechend Ja, ich habe jetzt einen Anstieg von ich sage mal 50 auf 70
im Kopf, aber es ist, ja, also es ist deutlich teurer geworden dort.
50 auf 70, ja 50 auf 50, genau, von 50 auf 55 irgendwie so in diesem Bereich,
teilweise aber auch schon mehr.
Also das ist ja auch ein Moving Target und es gibt auch Berichte,
dass halt der Russland jetzt anfängt, Sprit aus dem Ausland zu importieren,
sowohl aus Belarus als auch aus Kasachstan.
Die reiben sich natürlich die Hände.
Aber das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich krass, weil die ganze russische Wirtschaft
lebt davon, Öl zu verkaufen.
Das ist die Haupteinnahme dieses Staates.
Öl, also fossile Kraftstoffe aller Art in allen Formen.
Gas, Benzin, Diesel, Rohöl, alles mögliche.
Und jetzt durch diese Bombardierung der Raffinerien, die jetzt also in zunehmendem
Maße außer Betrieb genommen werden, ist auf einmal dieser Petro-Staat nicht
mehr in der Lage, sich selber zu versorgen, sondern muss,
das Land mit den größten Ölvorkommen, mit der größten Oil-Exploitation,
ich weiß nicht, die größten Vorkommen hat, auf jeden Fall hat es richtig viel.
Muss jetzt auf einmal selber Sprit kaufen.
Das heißt, nicht nur, dass sie dafür jetzt eine Menge Geld ausgeben müssen,
auf der anderen Seite kommt halt auch gar kein Geld mehr rein.
Das ist sozusagen eine Einschränkung ihrer Wirtschaftsfähigkeit schon mal ganz enorm.
Und es ist natürlich auch ein logistisches Problem, weil kein Sprit heißt,
Fahrzeuge können unter Umständen nirgendwo hinfahren.
Tankstellen gibt es halt jetzt bevorzugte Behandlung für Militärfahrzeuge oder
Krankenwagen oder Feuerwehr oder keine Ahnung, wer halt noch ein bisschen mehr zahlt wahrscheinlich.
Ja und das fällt auch langsam auf, weil das ist natürlich etwas,
was sich nicht so richtig verbergen lässt, wenn auf einmal überall lange Schlangen
an Tankstellen sind, weil das sind die Russen nicht gewohnt.
Plus Rationierungen, also stehst dann teilweise Stunde, zwei Stunden an und
dann gibt es halt maximal zwischen, je nachdem,
manchmal nur 10 Liter, manchmal bis zu 30 Liter pro Fahrzeug.
Aber das kostet natürlich dann auch, wenn Leute einfach eine Stunde oder zwei
Stunden Zeit investieren müssen, um ein paar Liter Sprit in ihr Auto zu kriegen.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht gut, so jetzt wirtschaftlich gesehen,
weil die nicht arbeiten können in der Zeit und ja, alles nicht gut.
Alles nicht gut. Und ja, die Angriffe gehen also immer weiter.
Die Russen selber können sich das offensichtlich immer noch nicht erklären,
aber es fällt natürlich auf und sogar das lokale Fernsehen berichtet, also jetzt schon davon.
Hast du immer diese schönen Interviews, wo sie dann immer alle so,
ja ich weiß auch nicht warum. warum?
Ja, das konnte ich, also jetzt auch drei oder vier verschiedene Interviews so,
ja irgendwie, wieso ist denn der Sprit knapp?
Ja, keine Ahnung, also wirklich sehr seltsam so.
Und denkst, das ist ja irre, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass die Russen oder,
haufenweise im Fernsehen gezeigt werden,
wie, ja, keine Ahnung, also kann ich mir nicht erklären.
So und dann auch genauso auch dann natürlich die Tankstelleninhaber oder klar,
das ist dann auch russisches Fernsehen, insofern weiß man dann nicht,
was andere Leute vielleicht gesagt haben, die dann nicht gezeigt wurden,
aber diese demonstrierte Ahnungslosigkeit,
Das fand ich schon verrückt, einfach.
Ja, also das hat natürlich massive Auswirkungen. 67 Prozent aller Tankstellen
in Russland sind privat betrieben und werden jetzt potenziell natürlich Insolvenz bedroht.
Man kann jetzt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass der Staat hier groß eine
Hilfestellung sein wird.
Das wird sich zeigen, was das für Auswirkungen hat. Aber unter Umständen gibt
es dann halt auch noch so ein Tankstellensterben.
Weil wenn du keinen Sprit kriegst, kannst du nichts verkaufen,
hast du keine Einnahmen, kannst du deine Kosten nicht tragen und dann müssen
die vielleicht zumachen.
Und dann hast du irgendwie weniger Tankstellen.
Also offensichtlich haben eine ganze Reihe dieser Tankstellen,
die dann nicht mit Sprit beliefert wurden, einfach schlichtweg zugemacht.
Und die Leute dann erstmal in Urlaub geschickt, weil was willst du denn da Leute hinstellen,
die dann ständig nur sagen, wir haben keinen Sprit oder so und manche sind dann
eben nur offen, wie du schon sagtest, für spezielle Bedarfsträger dann mit speziellem Ausweis,
das sind die Stadtverwaltung oder Feuerwehr, Polizei.
Oder du hast halt dann ausreichend gute Beziehungen, um dir so eine Karte dann
zu kaufen oder anderweitig korrupt zu erwerben.
Sozusagen dann die andere Art und Weise, wie du in Sprit kommst,
einfach mit Hilfe von Korruption.
Ja, das auch gehen.
Also das Ganze hat natürlich enorme Auswirkungen. Es ist ohnehin so,
dass alle großen Ölfirmen in Russland mittlerweile nur noch miese machen.
Also die Wirtschaft, die sozusagen bisher immer garantiert war,
dass sie Gewinne macht, macht Verluste.
Das betrifft alle großen, Rosneft, Lukoi, Gazprom, Tatenheft,
alle haben negative Geschäftszahlen.
Das heißt, da kommt halt auch keine Kohle mehr rein, werden sozusagen auch keine
Steuern generiert, dann wird es dann auch schwierig, die Gehälter zu bezahlen etc.
Und da die Inflation so groß ist, ist halt mit Krediten auch nicht so geil,
weil das wird dann erst richtig teuer.
Und was natürlich vielleicht noch ein größeres Problem ist, wenn jetzt das so
weiter geht und davon ist ja eigentlich auszugehen, dass es so weiter geht,
dann bricht unter Umständen an manchen Stellen auch die Produktionskette.
Weil mit dem Öl ist es halt so, das pumpst du nicht mal so on demand,
sondern wenn du da so ein Pumploch irgendwie offen hast, dann läuft der Kram einfach und,
wenn du das dann nicht geschippt bekommst, also wenn du das nicht wegbekommst,
wenn es einfach keinen Ort gibt, wo es raffiniert und wo es versendet werden
kann oder wo es auch nur gelagert werden kann, weil alles wird ja angegriffen.
Lager, Pipelines, Raffinerien, Terminals.
Wenn diese ganze Kette auseinanderbricht, dann hast du einen entsprechenden
Rückstau und wenn du so ein Bohrloch nicht permanent pumpst da in Sibirien,
dann frieren die ein und dann ist vorbei.
Das ist in den 90er Jahren schon mal passiert. Das war dann super teuer,
die wieder überhaupt in Betrieb zu nehmen, nur mit großen Investitionen des Westens.
Und keine Ahnung, wie nah Russland diesem Zustand jetzt schon ist,
aber das ist definitiv halt eine mittelfristige Auswirkung, die diese Angriffe haben können.
Ja, ich habe es ja erwähnt, auch die Pumpstationen werden angegriffen und das
finde ich jetzt überhaupt nochmal ganz interessant, das nochmal separat anzuschauen,
weil man macht sich das ja immer nicht so richtig klar, wie das so läuft.
Pipelines haben wir bisher immer so diskutiert mit, ja, die Pipeline,
die das dann nach Europa bringt oder in die Türkei und so weiter.
Klar, also diese Final Delivery direkt in ein Zielland oder zumindest in eine,
Zielwirtschaft, von der es dann nochmal weiter verteilt werden können.
Wir hatten das ja mit der Nord Stream Pipeline und es gibt ja auch dann die Pipelines im Süden.
Aber ich rede jetzt von den innerrussischen Pipelines.
Die, die quasi direkt von den Produktionsorten, also vor allem dann im Nordosten
kommen und zu den ganzen Raffinerien führen, die im Wesentlichen so im Westen sind.
Und vor allem übrigens auch dicht gedrängt um die Ukraine herum.
Also das ist sozusagen auch der Hotspot für Raffinerien.
Und diese Pipelines, die brauchen alle paar Kilometer so eine Pumpstation.
Mit anderen Worten, Russland ist voll mit Pumpstationen.
Und wenn halt irgendwie eine Pumpstation nicht mehr pumpt, dann war es das mit der Pipeline.
Mit anderen Worten, die Ukraine greift jetzt auch Pumpstationen an und wenn
diese Pumpstationen aufhören zu funktionieren und nicht schnell wieder repariert
werden kann, dann geht erstmal gar nichts weg vom Produktionsort.
Da dürften sie also mittlerweile auch ausreichend in Panik sein.
Am meisten Aufmerksamkeit hat natürlich der Angriff einer Pumpstation der sogenannten
Druschbar-Pipeline nach sich gezogen.
Die ist relativ nah an der Ukraine dran und diese spezielle Pipeline führt halt
in den Westen, unter anderem.
Aber es gibt auch also da wo sie es angegriffen haben das ist so kurz vor so
einer Weiche und es gibt dann einen Weg in den Westen und einen Weg in den Norden,
das ist diese Pumpstation Unetscha und der Weg nach Norden ist halt die Versorgung von St.
Petersburg und dort den Terminals und den Raffinerien die es dort nochmal gibt
Also Ust Luga ist ja einer dieser Raffinerien da direkt an der Ostsee,
die auch nochmal angegriffen wurde, aber eben schon vorher jetzt eben auch diese
Pipeline und zwar wurde die auch mehrfach angegriffen und die Westleitung,
die versorgt halt Ungarn,
Slowakei und Tschechien.
Also es ist eine sogenannte Southern Druschba-Linie und dann gibt es noch die Northern Druschba,
glaube ich, das geht nach Deutschland und Polen, die da eh nicht mehr in Betrieb
sind oder wo nichts mehr hingeliefert wird.
Und mit anderen Worten, der Angriff auf diese Pipeline war nicht nur ein Angriff
auf Russland, sondern es war auch noch ein Angriff auf Ungarn und die Slowakei
und im Prinzip auch Tschechien.
Aber ich glaube, die Tschechen sagen so, ja, okay, wir haben eh schon unsere
Alternativen organisiert.
Aber famously haben ja Ungarn und die Slowakei so einen sehr russlandfreundlichen Kurs.
Und Orban und Vizzo, die Staatschef von Ungarn und Slowakei,
die sind natürlich sofort durchgedreht und haben sich beschwert und überhaupt so was geht.
Und haben dann auch gleich Klage erhoben, die EU muss da jetzt mal was tun.
Wobei die EU dann einfach nur gesagt hat, Leute, was habt ihr denn eigentlich?
Ihr werdet ja sicherlich von diesem Krieg schon mal gehört haben,
der ist jetzt hier schon seit drei Jahren und ihr hättet ja mal vorsorgen können,
das hat sich doch eh abgezeichnet.
Und außerdem habt ihr doch noch Reserven, strategische Notfallreserven,
das wäre ja dann mal so ein Notfall, vielleicht probiert das erst mal da mit.
Case closed.
Also ich finde es schon auch immer wieder kurios, wie sich dann rausstellt,
dass dann doch noch irgendwo Kommerz mit der Russischen Föderation stattfindet.
Also zwischen West- und Russland und Energieexporte sind halt ein Beispiel dafür,
aber ja,
man sagt es jetzt mit Belarus oder überhaupt,
dass durch die Grenzsperrung oder das jetzt rauskam, dass Europa massiv chinesische
Waren importiert, die letztlich durch Russland und Belarus fließen,
wo man denken würde.
Dass das in einem Krieg eigentlich nicht passiert, dass man sich jetzt feindlich
gegenübersteht, Aber bis hin zu, ja,
jedes Mal, wenn irgendwie eine Grenze dicht gemacht wird zwischen Ost und West,
irgendwo, was weiß ich, in Finnland oder Norwegen oder im Baltikum,
stellt man fest, okay, da herrscht aber bisher ganz normaler Grenzverkehr offenbar,
trotz des Krieges, weil wir uns mit Russland eigentlich nicht im Krieg befinden oder nur so halb.
Oder also ja, das finde ich immer total überraschend, wenn irgendwo oder wenn
Sanktionen verschärft werden, denke ich mir immer aha,
okay es gibt also offensichtlich noch jede Menge Spielraum nach oben,
was jetzt Sanktionen angeht auch Ja.
Die Widerstände sind groß, auch Frankreich kauft noch sehr viel russisches Gas,
Und das kriegst du teilweise, denke ich mal, kriegst du es nicht so ohne weiteres Entflochten alles.
Oder zumindest gelingt es der Politik nicht, das zu entflechten.
Also Habeck hat ja hier eigentlich binnen kürzester Zeit russisches Gas und
die Versorgung mit fossilen Brennstoffen aus Russland zum Ende geführt.
Hier ist einfach schnell gehandelt worden.
Aber das ist jetzt in anderen Bereichen nicht unbedingt so der Fall.
Also ja, es ist absurd, dass wir da immer noch so viel Handel haben.
Aber wir wissen natürlich auch, wie schnell eine Wirtschaft zum Stillstand kommen
kann, wenn eben diese fossilen Quellen versiegen und man keinen guten Ersatz
dafür gefunden hat. Und das ist das Problem.
Ich meine,
wir haben ja jetzt, Zum einen erwähnt, okay, was macht Russland gerade,
was greifen sie an, was macht umgekehrt jetzt die Ukraine und ich frage mich dann halt auch immer,
okay, wenn eine Seite jetzt etwas macht, was erfolgreich ist,
so macht die andere Seite das auch und ist sie vielleicht auch erfolgreich damit?
Oder nicht oder hören wir nur nicht.
Also vielleicht auch noch zu erwähnen, dass natürlich unser Nachrichtenbild
oder die Nachrichtenlage immer irgendwie verzerrt ist.
Also wir kriegen zum Beispiel aus der Ukraine natürlich mit,
wenn Raketenangriffe, wenn die zivilen Ziele,
wenn die zerstört werden, kriegen wir immer mit, dass es dann immer.
In der Zeitung, also in der Ukraine,
da wird natürlich darüber berichtet, aber wenn Ostland jetzt erfolgreich ist
beim Angriff militärischer Ziele in der Ukraine, kriegen wir relativ wenig davon mit beispielsweise.
Und dann stellt sich natürlich mir immer die Frage, okay, wie sehr ist eigentlich
die Ukraine jetzt auch unter Druck?
Weil was wir jetzt nur, glaube ich, am Rande erwähnt hatten oder nur in der letzten Sendung,
dass Russland ja jetzt auch teilweise,
also ich glaube, die 1000 haben sie noch nicht erreicht, aber irgendwie 700,
800 Flugkörper manchmal losschickt
pro Angriff, die dann auch Ziele in der gesamten Ukraine angreifen.
Gelegentlich bekommen wir mit, wenn irgendwo auch militärische Ziele angegriffen
werden, aber eher selten so.
Und dann stellt sich natürlich auch mal die Frage, okay.
Die Ukraine, wie sieht es mit deren Logistik eigentlich aus,
um das Land zu versorgen?
Und wenn Russland eigentlich noch mit einem Vielfachen an Raketen und Marschflugkörpern angreift,
sind sie nicht auch in der Lage, die ukrainische Infrastruktur unter Druck zu
bringen oder sogar noch mehr unter Druck zu bringen, als jetzt die russische
Infrastruktur unter Druck steht.
Und das ist halt immer ganz schwer zu beantworten von hier.
Also es gibt ja auch Zeichen, dass auch natürlich die Ukraine,
dass es dort überall knirscht und knackt, was so Infrastruktur angeht.
Energieversorgung, Strom, Benzin, Waffen, also das ist glaube ich auch alles,
Knirsch in der Ukraine, aber davon bekommen wir halt nicht so viel mit.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Machen wir weiter mit den sonstigen Kampagnen, die die Ukraine extrem betreibt
und die dadurch sehr sichtbar werden.
Man weiß natürlich von vielen Sachen nicht, was läuft.
Im Idealfall machst du natürlich alles im Geheimen.
Auch wenn die Ukraine immer mal wieder selber Videos rausbringt und irgendwie
rumprallt und was auch immer sie damit für Hintergedanken haben,
das steht nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt.
Aber was auf jeden Fall sehr sichtbar ist,
ist der größere Erfolg, den sie zu haben scheinen im Kampf gegen die Luftabwehr
und auch Flugzeuge auf der Krim.
Also das ist schon ein Fokuspunkt, weil da gab es einfach jetzt so viele Bilder und so viele Meldungen.
Dass sie also am laufenden Meter Luftabwehrsysteme zerstören,
teilweise Flugzeuge, teilweise Hubschrauber und zwar sowohl durch einen direkten
Drohnenangriff, also vermutlich ist mir nicht so ganz klar, was jetzt sozusagen
dazu führt, aber definitiv auch mit ihren Marine Drones.
Also sie haben ja diese selbstfahrenden oder ferngesteuerten Mini-Boote,
die ja am Anfang so im Wesentlichen als Kamikaze-Fahrzeuge eingesetzt wurden,
so wie es die Russen jetzt eben auch machen,
aber die ja mittlerweile eher so Flugzeugträger sind oder Drohnenträger vielmehr.
Sprich, dann gab es jetzt gerade so ein Foto, weil so ein Ding wohl irgendwie
von Russen gefunden wurde.
Da sieht man mal ganz gut, wie das ist. Also es sieht halt aus wie so ein normales
Boot, schon recht groß, mit allerlei Funktechnik drauf, wahrscheinlich ein Starlink
oder ein Solarpanel nicht so ganz klar.
Und dann so vier Kästen, wo offensichtlich die Quadrokopter,
dann die FPV-Drohnen drin sind, die Angriffsdrohnen.
Das heißt, man fährt mit diesem Boot irgendwo in die Nähe eines Militärstandorts,
oder wo auch immer man angreifen möchte und dann gehen da die Deckel auf und
die FPV-Drohnen kommen raus und ich vermute mal, dass dann dieses Boot auch
selber so eine Art Funkrelay ist, das heißt, darüber werden dann die.
Videosignale von den FPV-Drohnen hin übertragen, sodass die Dinger eben aus
der Ferne gesteuert werden können.
Und dann suchen sie sich ihre Ziele und finden halt geparkte Hubschrauber und
Flugzeuge und was nicht alles.
Oder auch Glasfaserdrohnen teilweise. Sie sind dann sozusagen per Glasfaser
auch von den Marine Drones.
Ja, okay, das kann natürlich auch sein. Da habe ich noch gleich drüber nachgedacht.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall sehr erfolgreich. Und woran...
Kann man das messen, dass es erfolgreich ist?
Es gibt Hinweise, zum Beispiel, dass auf der Krim von der Ukraine mittlerweile
wieder diese Bayraktar-Drohnen eingesetzt werden.
Die hatten wir ja ganz am Anfang des Krieges.
Wir erinnern uns irgendwie Lieder, die darüber gedichtet wurden und so weiter.
Damit hatte die Ukraine einige Erfolge, bis dann die Russen ihre Abwehr darauf eingestellt haben.
Und da die Bayraktar-Drohnen halt relativ groß und relativ langsam sind,
waren sie dann einfach ein einfaches Ziel und dann ist man eben auf andere Techniken umgeschwenkt.
Dass die jetzt wieder Fliegen und Erfolg haben, zeigt vielleicht,
dass eben das mit der Luftabwehr auf der Krim gar nicht mal mehr so gut ist.
Kann man sich natürlich fragen, warum die Krim? Gut, also auf der einen Seite,
bietet es sich eben an, weil sie eben diese Marine Drones haben,
damit können sie jetzt im Asowschen Meer nicht einfallen und auch die anderen
umkämpften Gebiete, da haben sie halt einfach keine Schifffahrtswege,
insofern bietet es sich in gewisser Hinsicht an, das da zu machen, because we can.
Auf der anderen Seite kann das natürlich auch sehr gut bedeuten,
dass diese gezielte Kampagne einfach den Weg freiräumen soll für neuartige Waffensysteme,
die man sich vielleicht mit mehr Luftabwehr, die noch am Start ist,
nicht trauen würde zu versenden.
Ja, außerdem gibt es Angriffe auf die Eisenbahninfrastruktur und das ist so
ein bisschen doppelt gemoppelt, also auf der einen Seite gibt es halt auch Drohnenangriffe,
das machen übrigens die Russen mittlerweile auch, aber hat man auch von der Ukraine gesehen,
das heißt man schickt halt Drohnen los, die fahren dann den Zügen hinterher,
die zielen dann erstmal direkt auf die Lok,
explodieren dann halt, was weiß ich, Lokführertod, keine Ahnung,
Technik auch im Arsch, vielleicht ist die Explosion auch so stark,
dass schon etwas entgleist und damit kommt der ganze Zug zum Stehen und dann
sind es halt im Idealfall sind es dann halt.
Züge mit Öltankern oder so und dann kommen noch weitere Drohnen hinterher,
setzen die dann in Brand und dann ist das Ganze so ein richtiges Inferno.
Das ist so die eine Strategie, die derzeit extrem gefahren wird.
Dann gibt es Angriffe auf so die Infrastruktur, also die Stromunterverteilung,
also so Umspannwerke, die halt den Bahnstrom bereitstellen.
So es halt nicht mit Dieselloks gemacht wird, aber teilweise ist es halt auch
elektrifiziert, beziehungsweise brauchst du natürlich generell Strom für alles Mögliche.
Das sind auf jeden Fall auch Ziele.
Ja, und dann gibt es auch noch etwas, wo ich mich da auch da erinnere,
was schon ganz am Anfang von vielen Kommentatoren auf YouTube immer empfohlen wurde.
So nach dem Motto, ja geht doch einfach auf diese Schaltkästen, die überall rumstehen.
Also jede Bahnlinie braucht einfach immer wieder irgendwelche Steuerelektronik,
damit dort die Züge nicht ineinander reinfahren und da stehen dann alle paar
Kilometer so Schaltkäste rum, die halt jetzt nicht so gut bewacht sind und mittlerweile gibt es,
da so Sabotage-Truppen, es gibt da zum Beispiel so eine russische.
Also von Russen so Partisanen, Krieg irgendwie, wo die halt einfach sagen,
hier unser Staat ist scheiße, wir sabotieren jetzt hier die Infrastruktur.
Oder es kann natürlich auch genauso gut sein, dass es von dem russischen, von dem ukrainischen.
Auslandsgeheimdienst für Special Ops geleitet wird. Oder vielleicht auch beides, was weiß ich.
Auf jeden Fall, das findet halt auch statt, dass die Eisenbahninfrastruktur
derzeit massiv unter Feuer ist.
Ja, und das ist auch alles irgendwie nicht so richtig verwundernswert,
weil das sind ja alles sogenannte legitime militärische Ziele.
Aber jetzt scheint die Ukraine auch so ein bisschen schnauzvoll zu haben und
hat auch angekündigt, dass sie ab sofort auch Kraftwerke angreifen werden.
Das ist eher selten gewesen bisher, während die Russen halt ganz massiv die
Kraftfahrtinfrastruktur der Ukraine bombardiert hat,
hat die Ukraine darauf verzichtet. Warum?
Naja, weil es halt eigentlich Kriegsverbrechen ist, wenn es nicht ein klar militärisches Objekt ist.
Gut, das hat die Russen jetzt noch nie so besonders gestört,
aber mittlerweile ist die Ukraine also an so einen Punkt gekommen,
wo sie sich denken, naja, also wenn ihr das macht, dann machen wir das jetzt auch.
Da werdet ihr ja schon sehen, wo ihr da hinkommt und greifen halt so diese Thermal
Power Plants an, also Halskraftwerke, wo halt wahrscheinlich sowohl Wärme als
auch Strom erzeugt wird.
Und davon haben die Russen auch eine ganze Menge.
Und es gab jetzt zum Beispiel einen solchen Angriff bereits in Belgorod,
das ist ja so eine Stadt, die relativ nah am Norden der Ukraine ist und ja,
da gab es einen Stromausfall in der ganzen Stadt,
kein Wasser, kein Strom, also kein Wasser weil die Pumpen nicht laufen und generell
halt kein Strom und es sieht so aus, als ob die Ukraine sich jetzt hier einfach mehr traut. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was so den Umschwung da eingeleitet hat,
ob das sozusagen mit der neuen Position der USA irgendwie zusammenhängt oder
ob sie generell einfach an so einen Punkt gekommen sind, wo sie sagen,
ey, wenn die anderen die ganze Zeit hier sich so verhalten und das ist zu unserem
Nachteil, warum sollen wir uns da zurückhalten?
Also ich kann das auf jeden Fall ganz gut verstehen.
Und ja, auch das komplementiert jetzt diese gesamten Angriffsszenarien,
die die Ukraine ohnehin schon fährten, die wir jetzt hier auch berichtet haben.
Und es geht sogar so weit, dass Zelensky also gedroht hat, dass sollten die
Russen halt kief auf eine Art und Weise angreifen, dass es dort einen Blackout
gibt, dann wäre der Blackout auch in Moskau.
Ja, also ich denke, das gilt es auf jeden Fall im Auge zu behalten,
wie sich das entwickelt.
Also dieser Angriff auf Belgorod war halt ganz klar erstmal als Warnung zu verstehen.
Wir haben jetzt seitdem keine weiteren Angriffe gesehen unbedingt auf diese Infrastruktur.
Kann sein, dass die Ukraine wartet, bis es noch etwas kälter und dunkler wird.
Unklar.
Es kann auch sein, dass sie das jetzt einmal gemacht haben, um mal zu gucken,
wie der politische Fallout ist.
Und da kann man glaube ich sagen, im Wesentlichen hat das keiner groß thematisiert.
Ja. Also plus, wie die Russen dann reagieren werden.
Und die große Frage ist halt auch,
Wir haben immer wieder jetzt Meldungen bekommen über die Ausweitung der Produktion
von allen möglichen Fernwaffen,
sage ich mal.
Und ob die Ukraine, die Frage ist,
ob die Ukraine da jetzt ein bisschen auf Halde produziert und wir da irgendwann
massive Angriffe oder noch massivere Angriffe von der Ukraine sehen werden oder
ähnlich massive Angriffe wie die Russen sie bisher fahren.
Das ist im Moment noch ein bisschen unklar, aber ich habe das Gefühl,
da könnte was im Busch sein jetzt für Herbst und Winter.
Dann kommen wir doch mal so generell zu dem Block der Waffentechnik,
also was sich hier getan hat.
Ganz allgemein kann man erstmal feststellen, das sind jetzt auch Verlautbarungen
der Ukraine selbst, die sagt,
wir stellen mittlerweile oder wir stellen einen zunehmend größeren Anteil der
im Krieg verwendeten Waffen in der Ukraine selbst her. Ja,
das lässt sich jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres quantifizieren. Es flogen verschiedene
Zahlen, irgendwo zwischen 40
und 60 Prozent der eingesetzten Waffen kommen irgendwie aus der Ukraine.
Das war dann aber so ein bisschen unklar, der im Ausland eingesetzten Waffen
oder der insgesamt eingesetzten,
also sozusagen auf russischem Gebiet eingesetzten Waffen oder generell in diesem
Krieg eingesetzten Waffen bezog sich das nur auf die Angriffswaffen oder auch auf die Verteidigung,
weil bei der Verteidigung Luftabwehr hängen sie ja sehr von westlichen Systemen ab.
Und überhaupt, was heißt schon 40 Prozent?
Genau, ist das jetzt Wert?
Von was? Wert, Stückzahl? Genau, Gewicht.
Ja, Sprengkopfgröße. In der Regel nimmt man halt dann schon den Wert,
aber das ist dann auch misguided.
Das hilft dann auch nicht unbedingt,
sich ein klares Bild zu verschaffen, weil so eine Patriot-Rakete,
die sie zwischen ein und zwei Millionen kostet und letztlich, weiß ich nicht,
300 bis 1000 FPV-Drohnen entspricht.
Und ja, also da ist dann die Frage,
ist jetzt eine Patriot-Rakete, ist die jetzt äquivalent in ihrer Kampfkraft
zu 300 bis 1000 FPV-Drohnen?
Aber was wir, glaube ich, festhalten können ist,
dass mittlerweile die Ukraine einen signifikanten Teil der eingesetzten Waffen
selbst produziert und das ist
in bestimmten Bereichen wie eben Langstreckenraketen besonders wichtig,
weil eben die ganzen aus dem Ausland eingekauften Waffen ja immer allen möglichen
Einschränkungen unterliegen,
potenziellen Einschränkungen, was damit angegriffen werden kann und was nicht und so.
Und deswegen ist das in manchen Bereichen einfach besonders wichtig,
eigene Produktion zu haben, mal wichtiger in manchen Bereichen als in anderen.
Plus natürlich Risiko USA oder generell das Risiko abgeschnitten zu werden aus
irgendwelchen Gründen von Waffenlieferungen,
das einfach zu mitigieren. Ja.
Neue Versionen von existierenden Waffen und neue Waffensystemen stehen jetzt
gerade in der Diskussion.
Dann geht es zunächst einmal los mit der neuen Version der Neptun,
die sie also zunehmend weiterentwickeln, die ja ursprünglich so eine Schiffsabwehrrakete war,
die ja famously hier die Moskva abgeschossen hat, so das Starschiff der russischen
Riener im Schwarzen Meer.
Und die neue Neptun, die kann wohl 1000 Kilometer weit fliegen statt ursprünglich
300 Kilometer und hat so bessere Zielerfassung, das ist alles,
überarbeitet worden, also sozusagen auch optimiert fürs Land,
weil vorher war es ja quasi fürs Wasser gedacht, das ist schon mal eine andere Anforderung,
hat auch mehr Sprengkraft, ist noch nicht so ganz klar, inwiefern die schon
eingesetzt wurde oder nicht, aber das ist zum Beispiel etwas, was sich verbessert,
dann haben sie natürlich diese neuen, ja.
Also die Neptun haben wir jedenfalls jetzt mehrfach gehört, wurde sehr erfolgreich
gegen Landziele, also Raffinerien und so eingesetzt oder auch gegen,
also gegen Landziele generell haben wir da eine Handvoll Fälle,
wo die Ukraine gesagt hat, das waren Neptuns.
Ah ja, okay, gut, ja stimmt. Jetzt wo du es sagst, erinnere ich mich auch wieder dran.
Genau, es kamen bloß ein paar mehr Daten durch, was genau jetzt sozusagen da anders ist.
Ja, dann im Drohnenbereich ist natürlich am meisten Innovation.
Also es ist einfach irre und da hat auch, glaube ich, keiner so richtig einen
Überblick, was alles da noch zusätzlich entwickelt wird.
Also wir hatten ja schon hier die Diskussion, Bodendrohnen und so weiter,
die Mariendrones und natürlich vor allem jetzt die ganzen fliegenden Systeme.
Aber was hier hervorsticht, was man mal erwähnen muss, das sind die sogenannten Interceptor-Drones.
Das heißt, man hat jetzt als Abwehr gegen diese massive Angriffslast,
die durch diese Schahed-Drohnen, diese iranischen Drohnen, die,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Russen, die nennen ja irgendwie noch einen anderen Namen dafür,
die ja teilweise bis zu, also mehrere, was weiß ich, 500 pro Nacht irgendwie
über die Ukraine schicken.
Das ist ein großes Problem,
Auch wenn die theoretisch relativ einfach abzufangen sind, weil sie langsam
sind und laut sind und auch mittlerweile akustisch geortet werden können und so weiter.
Man muss halt also durch diese schiere Zahl an Drohnen, selbst wenn du 80 Prozent,
90 Prozent abschießt, hast du halt immer noch genug Ärger durch die,
die dann doch durchkommen.
Ja, plus was wir letztes Mal auch kurz, glaube ich, erwähnt hatten, ist,
dass die Russen natürlich die Schahids auch immer weiter verbessern,
dass die halt dann jetzt komplexere Flugprofile haben und teilweise dann auch
ausweichen oder andere Dinge damit tun, dass sie erst,
dass sie über der Stadt kreisen lassen für eine halbe Stunde,
um die Bevölkerung zu terrorisieren und all solche Dinge.
Kameras drauf installiert haben, Nachtsichtkameras gibt es jetzt offensichtlich
auch. Damit wurden dann auch schon Züge angegriffen.
Also das ist so eine Technologie, auf der sie aufbauen und deswegen war es für
die Ukraine sehr wichtig, da ein Gegenmittel zu finden.
Und natürlich kannst du die mit so einer F-16 abschicken, aber die Ukraine hatte
einfach keine 500 F-16s, die rumkreisen können, um irgendwie all diese Drohnen,
die ja dann auch wirklich über das ganze Land abregnen, zu bekommen.
Und deswegen haben sie jetzt so eine Serie von verschiedenen Arten von Interceptor-Drones gebaut.
Das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, aber das hatten wir glaube ich auch schon besprochen,
die halt so super, super schnell sind, die irgendwie so 300,
400 Stundenkilometer erreichen können und die offensichtlich auch mit diesen
Sensornetzwerken verbunden sind.
Das heißt, wenn dann irgendwie akustisch so eine Schahed geortet wird,
dann stehen die sozusagen überall schon startbereit herum und wenn eben in einem
Einzugsgebiet einer Drohne so eine Schahed detektiert wird,
dann fliegen diese Interceptor Drones mehr oder weniger automatisch los und
orten das Ding und schießen es ab.
Und das ist wohl relativ erfolgreich. Je nachdem, wie man so glauben mag,
braucht man so ein bis drei Drohnen, um erfolgreich eine Schahedt abzuschießen.
Puh, ja, so 1000, 1500 Drohnen pro Tag, um irgendwie 500 Drohnen abzuwehren.
Das klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal viel, aber das ist ja nun mal eine massive Materialschlacht.
Aber die Produktionskapazität der Ukraine ist wohl so schlecht nicht.
Trotz alledem fängt man damit nicht alles ab, aber so oder so ist das natürlich
ökonomisch sehr interessant, weil jetzt fliegt da keine teure,
millionenteure F-16, von denen es nur wenige gibt, mit teuer ausgebildeten Piloten
durch die Gegend, um so ein Schahed abzufangen, sondern man kann das mit diesen
automatisierten Drohnen machen. Das scheint immer besser zu funktionieren.
Und ja, der Preisvorteil ist natürlich enorm.
Das heißt, der Aufwand der Ukraine, um so ein Ding abzuwehren,
liegt vielleicht beim Zehntel von dem, was die Russen investieren müssen,
um so ein Ding überhaupt erstmal zu bauen und auf den Weg zu bringen.
Naja.
Das ist auch, sagen wir mal, etwas, was das Ausland jetzt auch gemerkt hat.
Wir kommen ja nachher noch zu diesen Überflügen in Polen und so.
Also das Interesse an dieser Interceptor-Drone-Technology ist relativ groß.
Und es gibt ja auch andere Waffentechniken, die die Ukraine jetzt entwickelt
hat, die jetzt so in zunehmendem Maße in den Interessenbereich anderer westlicher Länder gekommen ist.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass eben für die Ukraine auch kurzfristig schon
schon Einnahmen entstehen, indem sie tatsächlich Militärtechnik auch verkaufen
oder entweder die Technologie als solche lizenzieren oder vielleicht sogar auch
aus eigener Produktion.
Das müssen Sie selber entscheiden, wo Sie meinen, genug Produktionen zu haben.
Oder vielleicht ist das auch nur so ein bisschen für die Zukunft.
Auf jeden Fall findet das statt.
Eine unschöne Sache an diesen Interceptor-Drohnen.
Ist, dass die natürlich auch erhebliche Proliferationsrisiken mit sich bringen.
Das heißt, unabhängig jetzt, ob es sich jetzt um ukrainische Drohnen handelt,
aber diese Technologie wird natürlich durch den Erfolg eher um sich greifen.
Und die technologischen Hürden sind natürlich relativ niedrig und die Dinger
sind auch relativ günstig.
Und die Frage ist, welche Gefahr dann jetzt für irgendwelche Terroraktionen
oder ähnliches von dieser Technologie ausgeht.
Also weil wir haben ja auch gesehen, dass mit diesen Drohnen auch schon russische
Flugzeuge, also Hubschrauber, ich glaube mindestens,
also ich glaube zwei Hubschrauber wurden mittlerweile abgeschossen mit Hilfe
dieser Drohnen, auch wenn die nicht dafür eigentlich gemacht sind.
Aber sagen, der Gedanke daran.
Dass Leute für ein paar tausend Euro Drohnen bauen können, mit denen man Flugzeuge abschießen kann,
ist, ja, also ich fände es besser, wenn dem nicht so wäre, aber ja.
Die Katze ist bereits aus dem Sack. Ja, und das schon länger.
Ich meine, da brauchst du noch nicht mal die Interceptor-Drones.
Also man kann im Prinzip mit einer ganz normalen FPV-Drohne,
wie es es ja auch schon seit zehn Jahren gibt, kannst du solche Angriffe fliegen,
wenn du keine entsprechende Verteidigung dagegen hast.
Und das ist halt ein generelles Problem natürlich der technologischen Entwicklung,
die jetzt durch diesen Krieg natürlich nochmal beschleunigt wird,
aber das ist ja in dem Sinne nichts Neues.
Also hier muss man über entsprechende Abwehrmechanismen sich Gedanken machen, gar keine Frage.
Zunächst einmal hat aber jetzt im Krieg die Ukraine in der Nase vorn,
auch wenn es natürlich durchaus vorstellbar ist, dass auch die Russen so etwas bauen wollen.
Nichtsdestotrotz haben die Ukrainer hier immer noch den Vorteil,
dass ihr zu verteidigendes Gebiet, obwohl die Ukraine groß ist,
ist es halt kein Vergleich zu dem, wie es in Russland ist.
Und die Russen können halt einfach rein quantitativ überhaupt nicht ihr Gebiet so schützen.
Sie können natürlich anfangen, solche Interceptor-Drones um ihre Raffinerien
herum zu platzieren. Das werden sie sicherlich auch versuchen.
Aber bisher sind
Ist davon noch nicht sehr viel bekannt. Sie arbeiten sozusagen noch mit Ihren
klassischen Luftabwehrsystemen S300, S400 und kleinere Systeme.
Und so viel Erfolg scheinen Sie damit ja nicht zu haben.
Ich meine, eine weitere Sache, die mir aber noch aufgefallen ist,
speziell auch bei den Interceptor-Drohnen, aber auch bei vielen anderen,
aber weil diese Interceptor-Drohnen sind ja, haben ja so Stromlinien, farmige,
hoch aerodynamische Verkleidung,
damit sie so schnell fliegen können und die scheinen mir alle aus 3D-Druckern zu stammen.
Ja.
So. Und das ist zwar auf der einen Seite, super, da kann man dann schnell neue
Iterationen machen, neue Versionen und so.
Aber auf der anderen Seite für Massenproduktion natürlich ist das nicht unbedingt ideal.
Also wenn du, was weiß ich, Spritzgussmaschinen und Formen hast,
kannst du da zigtausende am Tag von raushauen.
Und ja, so viele 3D-Drucker kannst du gar nicht betreiben.
Auf der anderen Seite, Vorteil natürlich für die Ukraine ist,
dass mit einem 3D-Drucker kannst du, sag mal, brauchst du nur einen Raum irgendwo
in einem Apartmentgebäude oder irgendwo in einer Garage und kannst dort Drohnen bauen.
Also da frage ich mich, an welchem Punkt werden welche Drohnentypen vielleicht
so weit entwickelt sein,
dass es sich lohnt, dann wirklich eine industrielle Massenproduktion dafür loszutreten
oder wo passiert das schon.
Und da habe ich das Gefühl, so diese Massenproduktion in dem Sinne existiert noch nicht.
Also ich habe noch nicht das Gefühl, dass irgendwie so ein deutscher Automobil
oder großer Rüstungshersteller oder so, sodass da wirklich eine Fertigungsstraße aufgesetzt wurde,
die dann 1.000, 10.000,
20.000 Drohnen am Tag hinten rauswirft.
Ja, was sicherlich auch damit zu tun hat, dass eben hier permanent iteriert wird.
Also die Anforderungen ändern sich ja am laufenden Meter.
Als ich in der Ukraine war, war ich ja bei so einer Bude, die auch so Drohnentechnik macht.
Die meinten halt so, naja, alle drei Monate ist wieder alles anders.
Also das, worauf man sich sozusagen technologisch einstellt und die Anforderungen
an der Frontlinie, die eben von allen möglichen Faktoren abhängen,
ändern sich innerhalb von drei Monaten so dermaßen, dass du im Prinzip deine
alten Designs schon wieder wegwerfen kannst.
Und Interceptor-Drones, die jetzt vielleicht vielversprechend sind,
müssen vielleicht aerodynamisch, keine Ahnung, motortechnisch,
sensortechnisch wieder so angepasst werden an irgendeinen neuen Angriffsvektor
innerhalb kürzester Zeit, dass da gar kein Nutzen daraus entstehen könnte,
dass du sowas massiv rausballern kannst.
Gut, kann man natürlich sagen, die Russen haben das ja jetzt auch gemacht,
zum Beispiel mit diesen Schahett-Drohnen, die haben jetzt mehrere Fabriken gebaut,
wo sie diese Dinger in großen Stückzahlen raushauen und das macht ja auch sehr
viel Ärger in der Ukraine.
Insofern ist da sicherlich irgendwas möglich, aber ich kann mir das sehr gut
vorstellen, dass man jetzt so zumindest mittelfristig so auf so einem brauchbaren
allgemeinen Design landet, wo man zumindest Teile davon besser automatisieren kann.
Also wie gesagt, mein Gefühl ist, wir sind da noch, was jetzt so den Drohnenkrieg
und Dinge angeht, ist da noch viel Luft nach oben, so was Produktionskapazitäten angeht.
Das denke ich auch.
Genau, viel Luft nach oben scheint auch noch bei der Flamingo-Rakete zu sein.
Die haben wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon kurz angedeutet,
weil die ja dort vorgestellt worden ist.
Zur Erinnerung Flamingo FP5. Flamingo heißt sie glaube ich deshalb,
weil irgendein Prototyp mal irgendwie so rosa war und deswegen haben sie Flamingo
genannt und dann sind sie gleich bei dem Namen geblieben.
Eine extrem reichweitenstarke Rakete, die 3000 Kilometer weit kommen soll und
eine Tonne Sprengstoff mit sich führen kann.
Also quasi von seinen Parametern her weiter ist als zum Beispiel die Tomahawk-Raketen
der Amerikaner und die wohl auch sehr niedrig fliegen kann,
die mit so einem Booster ausgestattet ist und von daher auch von einer kleinen
Rampe gestartet werden kann.
Das heißt, die kann man irgendwo hinfahren. Die ist auf so einem kleinen Anhänger.
So klein ist er nicht, aber auf so einem Anhänger, wo die drauf ist.
Und dann entfernt man sich und startet das Ding. Dann startet dieser Booster,
schickt das Ding erstmal kräftig in die Höhe.
Und wenn der Booster dann die Mindestgeschwindigkeit aufgebaut hat,
dann startet das eigentliche Triebwerk. Und dieser Booster wird dann wieder komplett abgeworfen.
Ja, diese Flamingo kann also von überall gestartet werden, wo normalerweise
eigentlich ein Flugzeug nötig wäre und jetzt warten alle so ein bisschen darauf,
dass das Ding auch wirklich mal zum Einsatz kommt, weil man hat halt gesagt,
ja kein Problem, wir können da irgendwie eine pro Tag produzieren und vielleicht
haben wir demnächst auch die Kapazität sieben pro Tag zu machen.
Keiner weiß jetzt, wo man da genau ist und wie lange das vielleicht noch dauern
kann, aber es klang alles so nach, ja die ist jetzt irgendwie fertig und die ist richtig toll.
Und es gibt einen Angriff, der in der Krim, also relativ nah noch an der Front
durchgeführt worden ist, auf so einen Stützpunkt der Russen,
wo offenbar drei Flamingo-Raketen zum Einsatz kamen.
Zumindest hat die Ukraine das gesagt oder Bilder veröffentlicht,
wo so drei Starts hintereinander zu sehen waren.
Weiß man natürlich immer nicht, ob das alles jetzt so dann auch wirklich so war, Bilder und so.
Aber das war quasi die Erzählung und später wurde dann eben analysiert,
was dieser Angriff so bewirkt hat. und naja, das war wohl nur so begrenzt erfolgreich.
Also es gab wohl einen direkten Treffer auf dieses Gebäude, was wohl ordentlich Schaden genommen hat.
Aber dann gab es noch einen zweiten Einschlag und der war dann so 100 Meter,
weiter weg und ich glaube, war das schon fast am Wasser, fast am Ufer,
also zumindest nicht auf das eigentliche Ziel.
Und von der dritten, die angeblich losgeschickt wurde, ist nichts gesehen worden.
Also entweder ist die abgeschossen worden oder die ist irgendwie alleine abgestürzt
oder ganz woanders hingeflogen, weiß man nicht genau.
Und naja, und alle dachten so, okay, das ist jetzt hier so der Beta-Test und
jetzt gucken wir mal, was hier als nächstes passiert.
Und seitdem ist eigentlich nichts passiert. Also man wartet so ein bisschen
drauf, dass jetzt irgendwie die Flamingos auf einmal gen Osten ziehen,
aber das steht irgendwie alles noch aus und muss man mal gucken,
ob das jetzt alles nur Vaporware ist oder ob von diesem Raketen- und Waffensystem
noch eine größere Gefahr ausgeht.
Ja, das ist immer so bei neuen Waffensystemen.
Die klingen oft im Vorfeld sehr vielversprechend, aber am Ende weiß man erst,
ob sie wirklich was taugen, wenn sie sich dann an der Front bewährt haben.
So, und ja, bei den Flamingos bleibt es abzuwarten, ich meine,
die haben halt auch gewisse Nachteile.
Einmal ist es halt eine sehr große Waffe, so, das heißt, du brauchst halt auch entsprechend,
ja, große Fahrzeuge, um die dann zu starten und so.
Also es ist, du kannst die nicht einfach aus einem Container starten,
aber wer weiß, vielleicht machen sie jetzt neue Startanlagen und so.
Also es ist schwieriger, die nochmal verborgen zu halten beispielsweise und ja,
der Aufwand natürlich, die zu bauen und zu produzieren, ist auch größer als
bei jetzt kleineren Waffen,
schlicht einfach wegen der Masse auch.
Und deswegen, ja, muss man halt sehen.
Entscheidend ist auf dem Platz.
Ja, entscheidend ist auf dem Platz, genau.
Und dann weiß man auch nicht, wie es um den Radarquerschnitt bestellt ist.
Aber grundsätzlich haben natürlich größere Raketen auch einen größeren Querschnitt.
Und dann kommt auch viel auf die Programmierung an. Wie tief kann die fliegen?
Kann die jetzt irgendwie zumindest ansatzweise Terrain-Matching machen oder
Terrain-Kontur-Matching?
Also kann die jetzt tief fliegen und dann durch Täler und so weiter sich navigieren,
um sich vor Radar zu schützen oder muss sie konstant in ein paar hundert Metern Höhe fliegen?
Das sind alles Fragen, wo wir noch nicht genau wissen,
was steckt denn da an Technologie drin und wie gut kann sich die Waffe auch
verbergen und tief ins Hinterland vordringen.
Das bleibt alles abzuwarten.
Ja
Firepoint heißt die Firma, die das produziert,
die wollen auch noch andere, die
wollen auch Luftabwehrsysteme bauen und noch ballistische Raketen also diese
Flamingo heißt eigentlich FP5 und dann wollen sie noch eine FP7 und FP9 machen
und sammeln wohl irgendwie auch Kohle für ein und Dänemark hat wohl auch zugesagt,
dass sie die Produktion für den Treibstoff auch übernehmen.
Muss man schauen, was dabei rauskommt.
Die USA wiederum haben offenbar zugesagt, Ende August kam das raus,
binnen sechs Wochen, sprich jetzt müsste das eigentlich auch bald mal passieren,
noch sogenannte IRAM-Missiles zu liefern.
Das ist natürlich einerseits schon bemerkenswert, überhaupt mal irgendeine Zusage von den USA zu sehen.
Bezahlen tun es natürlich die Europäer. Nicht, dass jetzt man auf einmal davon
ausgeht, Trump würde irgendwie die Ukraine so richtig unterstützen wollen.
Aber abkaufen lassen sie sich das Zeug halt schon.
Sprich, die Europäer müssen jetzt den Amerikanern dafür was bezahlen,
dass die Ukraine eine neue Technik bekommt. Das ist alles so schäbig.
Also diese ERA-Missiles sind wohl ganz interessant. Da werden wohl so über 3.300,
geliefert werden, wenn es klappt.
Und das sind so Air-Launched-Missiles. Also die kann man dann halt an so F-16
und was weiß ich, vielleicht auch an die russischen Modelle hängen,
das weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
450 Kilometer Reichweite, das könnte also auch noch,
die Verteidigungs- oder Angriffsfähigkeit der Ukraine verbessern.
Ja, sind wohl auch Low-Cost irgendwie, das ist so um die 30.000 Dollar pro,
Das.
Ist im Prinzip auch so wie diese Gleitbombs in dieser Kategorie, oder?
Ja, also im Grunde genommen, was ich richtig verstanden habe,
sind das mehr oder weniger,
Gleitbomben mit Raketenantrieb.
Und ja, man kann auch sehen,
wie gut die sind. Also da haben wir schon Verschiedenes erlebt.
Und unter anderem auch mit GLDB,
die Ground Launched Small Diameter Bombs, die sich nicht so bewährt haben,
wo man auch extra für die Ukraine versucht hat,
Sprengkörper auf Raketen zu setzen, die schon existierten für andere Zwecke.
Und ja, dieses Iram scheint mir auch so ein Frankenstein-System zu sein,
wo man aus mehreren existierenden Dingen irgendwas zusammengestöpselt hat,
was billig ist und wo man sehen muss, wie gut das funktionieren wird.
Wie gut das funktioniert.
Ja, dann vielleicht noch eine Sache, relativ frisch gemeldet,
hat aber durchaus die Augenbraue nach oben gezogen.
Wir hatten ja auch schon berichtet, dass in zunehmendem Maße diese Glasfaser-gesteuerten
Drohnen zum Einsatz kommen.
In zunehmendem Maße übrigens so dermaßen zunehmend, dass das schon eine potenziell
absehbare große Umweltbelastung darstellen wird, Weil einfach in der Ukraine,
jetzt in den umkämpften Gebieten, überall wie riesige Spinnennetze sieht das aus,
die sich über diese ganze Fläche ausbreiten.
Weil Glasfaser heißt ja im Prinzip, die Drohnen fliegen los und lassen die ganze
Zeit halt so eine Glasfaser von der Rolle hinter sich, die dann so langsam zum Boden sinkt.
Die Glasfaser ist so leicht, dass sich die Drohne jetzt beim Fliegen nicht groß
behindert und die bleibt dann halt irgendwie auf den Bäumen,
auf den Gräsern, was auch immer, auf der Umwelt so liegen und also alles ist
irgendwie mit diesen Glasfaserdingern abgedeckt.
Und das wird natürlich auch nochmal interessant zu sehen, was das für die Natur
für eine Auswirkung hat.
Aber vor allem ist es jetzt erstmal im Krieg natürlich eine Bedrohung,
weil hier natürlich die Electronic Warfare-Abwehrsysteme nicht so gut funktionieren.
Und eine wie ich finde ganz pfiffige Methode von der man mal schauen muss wie
effektiv sie ist wird jetzt wohl von der Ukraine zum Einsatz gebracht wird indem sie ein,
wie heißt das? Konzertiner Draht?
Ja, Konzertiner war ja im Prinzip NATO-Draht hatten wir das NATO-Stacheldraht
hatten wir das glaube ich früher genannt es ist jedenfalls Stacheldraht im Prinzip,
wobei das ein Draht ist,
wo dann halt so, ich sag mal, kleine Messer aufgeschweißt sind.
So die, ja, kleine Stanzbleche, scharfe Stanzbleche, die dann so in beide Richtungen
irgendwie das Ding, ja, unangenehm machen.
Und genau, diesen Draht kann man jetzt dazu benutzen, indem man ihn über ein
paar hundert Meter einfach spannt.
Also gerade und nicht so in so einen Ring, wie man das normalerweise zum Einsatz bringen würde.
Sondern gerade und dann an eine Seite oder an beide Seiten im Prinzip einen.
Motor heransetzt und das auf Stützen so lagert,
dass sich der Draht frei drehen kann und dann im Prinzip rotiert.
Und was dann halt passiert ist, wenn dann dort so eine Glasfaserdrohne drüber fliegt,
legt sich die Faser dann auf den Draht und der schnappt sich dann die Faser
und wickelt die dann auf und schneidet die durch.
Oder es reicht halt auch schon, wenn du sie scharf genug knickst,
um dann das Licht abzudrehen.
Die haben halt so einen Mindestradius, den sie haben müssen,
damit das noch funktioniert mit dem Licht dadurch. und ja, das fand ich halt eine Interesse.
Das ist wirklich pfiffig, vor allem die muss ich ja auch nicht besonders schnell
drehen, also die kann sich sehr langsam,
drehen und es ist schon effizient und das kriegt man dann in the field natürlich
auch sehr leicht hin mit einem Motor, also das Hauptproblem glaube ich ist diese Spannung,
also wirklich, wenn man jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe gelesen,
was von 100 Meter Abschnitten, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, 100 Meter?
Wie willst du denn 100 Meter Natodraht, das ist ja sauschwer, 100 Meter Natodraht.
Ja, mit Stützen.
Ja, klar, mit Stützen, aber das wird ja trotzdem durchhängen.
Also entweder hängt es halt besonders hoch.
Wenn du alle 10 Meter oder so, hast du alle 10 Meter einen Zaunfall durchgehängt.
Achso, und dann ist die Rotation.
Genau, und dann hast du einfach eine Buchse, wo das durchgeführt ist,
wo sich der Draht frei drehen kann.
Okay, na gut, die werden es auf jeden Fall ausprobiert haben.
Das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren, aber du brauchst eigentlich keinen mega
starken Motor, beziehungsweise du musst ihn nicht besonders schnell drehen.
Das heißt, man kommt mit relativ wenig Strom aus.
Und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es ausreicht, da ein Solarpanel dran
zu haben. vielleicht noch einen Akku für die Nacht, dass die Dinger sich quasi
permanent langsam drehen.
Was ich gesehen habe, war, dass sie Autobatterien da dran hatten im Prinzip.
Das sah aus wie Autobatterien, womit sie das angetrieben haben.
Und die Dinger waren nicht permanent in Betrieb,
sondern werden dann quasi remote gestartet und haben dann einen Timer und laufen
dann so für zehn Minuten oder so, wenn die getriggert werden.
Das war...
Also sozusagen so als aktive Maßnahme, wenn man hört, so hier sind Drohnen im
Einsatz, dann schalten wir das jetzt mal ein und dann wird da sozusagen so ein
Gebiet damit abgesichert.
Ja, oder teilweise kann es sein, dass sie auch mit automatischen Triggern experimentieren.
Aber ich glaube, dass sie die tatsächlich manuell triggern, dass da Leute dann
im Schützengraben sitzen und wenn die hören, da kommt was, dann drücken die
auf den Knopf und dann läuft das Ding für 10 Minuten.
Wie hoch mag so eine Drohne fliegen? Wahrscheinlich...
Wie gesagt, die Höhe spielt keine Rolle, die Glasfaser legt sich auf den Boden.
Wie weit kann die Drohne über diesen Draht rüberfliegen, bevor sie durchtrennt wird?
Also umso höher sie fliegt, umso weiter kann sie ja im Prinzip kommen,
aber wahrscheinlich legt sich diese Glasfaser relativ schnell.
Ja, das sind ein paar Dutzend Meter maximal.
Das heißt, das Ding ist dann auch schnell im Eimer. Auch wenn sich das Ding
nicht dreht, könnte der Draht schon an sich einiges verhindern.
Aber das Drehen bringt es wahrscheinlich dann nochmal extra.
Also der Draht selber macht da nicht viel, solange er sich nicht dreht.
Aber es gibt auch noch andere Verfahren, die erprobt werden, um die zu durchtrennen.
Also Hitze hilft auch, weil obwohl die Dinger Glasfaser heißen,
sind die eigentlich Kunststoff.
Also sind Hitze empfindlich auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, du kannst sie auch dann teilweise
mit Hitze oder mit anderen Schneidwerkzeugen und so, bis hin zu, ja,
es gab da ein russisches Video, wo sie damit tatsächlich mit einer Schere rangegangen
sind, wo sich einer versteckt hat.
Und dann halt mit der Schere die Glasfaser durchgeschnitten hat.
Okay, ja, das ist immer wieder interessant, wie viel gegenseitig immer wieder
neue Methoden erfunden werden, um die anderen pfiffigen Methoden wieder zu untergraben.
Und wenn die Faser durchgeschnitten wird, im Prinzip, was ich gesehen habe,
stürzen die Drohnen sofort ab und explodieren.
Also wenn die Faser durchschneidest, ist das Ding in ein, zwei Sekunden auf
dem Boden und explodiert.
Nun gut soviel vielleicht zur militärischen Situation und Waffentechnik jetzt
kommen wir mal so ein bisschen auf die,
sonstigen Rahmenbedingungen die noch ganz interessant sind und wir dachten uns
es ist mal ganz interessant überhaupt mal auf die Situation in Russland mal
wieder hinzuweisen Wie geht es dem Land eigentlich derzeit so?
Und ich glaube, es lässt sich sagen, nicht so richtig geil.
Also das bezieht sich,
bevor wir vielleicht auf Russland gehen, nochmal überhaupt die Situation in
den besetzten Gebieten, also vor allem Luhansk und Donetsk und natürlich auch da und Mariupol,
all diese ganzen von den Russen eingenommenen und kontrollierten Gebiete.
Da gibt es also Berichte von einer extremen Wasserknappheit zum Beispiel,
also dass einfach da keine ordentliche Wasserinfrastruktur mehr am Start ist
und es einfach kein sauberes Wasser gibt, wenn es überhaupt Wasser gibt.
Das überrascht einen vielleicht auch nicht so besonders, aber die Infrastruktur
leidet natürlich unter diesem Krieg doppelt und dreifach.
Aber in Russland selber läuft es auch nicht so gut, weil einfach die russische
Wirtschaft jetzt zunehmend unter Druck gerät.
Also haben wir ein paar Sachen schon angesprochen.
Derzeit steigt die Inflation stark an, die Zinsen sind halt auch extrem hoch für Kredite.
Und wir hatten ja glaube ich vor ein, zwei Sendungen hatten wir schon mal auch
so diese allgemeine wirtschaftliche Situation und wie sich das so entwickelt hat.
Beobachtet und da war doch so die Gesamtsituation eher so dass es so einen Fake-Aufschwung
gab weil einfach der Staat so viel Kohle,
reinbuttert in den Militärapparat und das hat dann dazu geführt,
dass eben um gute Leute anzuwerben oder überhaupt Leute anzuwerben für die Waffenproduktion,
relativ hohe Gehälter gezahlt werden, die Gehälter steigen.
Das hat natürlich dann auch Auswirkungen gehabt auf die restliche Wirtschaft,
die dann damit sozusagen auch konkurrieren muss.
Und so gab es so eine Art Fake-Aufschwung, weil auf einmal so viel Geld in die
Soldaten gesteckt wurde, damit die bereit sind mitzukämpfen.
Dadurch konnten die sich auf einmal viel leisten und genauso eben die Angestellten
in der Militärindustrie und die Wirtschaft musste eben versuchen irgendwie mitzuhalten.
Aber das war halt eh klar, dass das irgendwann auch so an ein Ende kommt.
Und an dem Punkt sind wir jetzt, glaube ich, so langsam angekommen.
Die Gehälter gehen jetzt langsam wieder zurück. Also man hat so untersucht,
was so an Stellenausschreibungen ist.
Und es waren die Gesuche im Waffenproduktionsbereich, im militärischen Komplex.
Einerseits waren es sehr, sehr, sehr viele Stellen, die dort besetzt werden
sollten. Also es gab sehr viele Gesuche und dann haben halt Leute diese Ausschreibungen
gescannt und verglichen, was da so für Gehaltsangebot gemacht werden und die
Gehälter gehen also jetzt wieder zurück.
Was einfach damit zu tun hat, dass diese Unternehmen kein Geld verdienen.
Also diese ganzen Produktionsfirmen werden quasi vom Staat gezwungen zu produzieren,
aber sie können halt nicht zu Bedingungen produzieren, indem sie in irgendeiner Form Geld verdienen.
Und das zeigt sich halt jetzt so langsam und das hat natürlich dann auch Auswirkungen
auf die ganze restliche Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft und wird dazu führen,
dass sich das eben in zunehmendem Maße das Geschäftsklima dort,
abkühlt und dazu kommt natürlich dieses permanente Problem, was halt viele,
gute, hochqualifizierte Leute, die keinen Bock auf Krieg haben,
haben das Land halt verlassen oder sind vielleicht auch noch dabei,
es zu verlassen. Viele sind schon gegangen.
Viele gehen einfach in den Krieg.
Andere verstecken sich und haben Angst, wenn sie irgendwo einen Job annehmen,
dann rekrutiert zu werden. Das gab es ja auch.
Also es gibt da viele Aspekte, die dazu führen, dass einfach die Wirtschaft
unter immer schwierigen Bedingungen arbeiten muss und das führt natürlich dann
auch zu weniger Wirtschaftsleistungen,
das führt zu weniger Steuern und dadurch wird diese Spirale nur noch weiter angespornt.
Jetzt hat Putin auch angekündigt, die Umsatzsteuer zu erhöhen.
Das bedeutet, es wird also auch noch weiteres Geld von der Gesellschaft an sich
noch genommen werden. Das wird auch nicht gut enden.
Ja, und dann hat das Finanzministerium auch noch so ein bisschen seine Zahlen
veröffentlicht und die Wirtschaft macht halt überhaupt gar keinen Gewinn mehr.
Also es ist halt einfach ein fortgesetztes Defizit und auch der Ausblick für
die nächsten Jahre ist defizitär.
Da haben wir so ein bisschen die Zahlen hier so interpretiert und es sieht so
aus, als ob es allein in diesem Jahr so ein 50 Milliarden Euro Minus geben wird
nach aktueller Prognose und man kann davon ausgehen,
dass auch die offizielle Prognose eher noch schönfärberisch unterwegs ist.
Dazu eben, wie schon erwähnt, keine Einnahmen mehr durch,
also nicht keine Einnahmen, aber deutlich weniger Einnahmen durch den Verkauf
von Öl und entsprechenden Produkten und da das halt so die primäre Stütze der Wirtschaft ist,
wird es schwierig. Der Ölpreis ist gesunken.
OPEC hat sogar angekündigt, noch die Produktion zu erhöhen. Da soll die Arabien
und so weiter sagen, ja, wir produzieren jetzt mal wieder mehr,
was ja in der Regel dann dazu führt, dass der Ölpreis noch weiterfällt.
Sieht nicht so geil aus, wenn du mich fragst. Und das trägt so ein bisschen
dazu bei, dass man so den Eindruck bekommt, dass für Russland jetzt eine neue Phase beginnt.
Ja, ich meine, du hast jetzt sehr oft den Begriff die russische Wirtschaft erwähnt
und so für mich sieht es halt so aus,
dass die russische Wirtschaft zunehmend der ähnelt,
wie wir sie im Dritten Reich in Deutschland hatten.
Also auf der einen Seite hast du halt ja schon so eine Art Kapitalismus,
also privates Unternehmertum.
Firmen werden nicht verstaatlicht oder so wie im Kommunismus,
sondern gibt es halt Unternehmer.
Aber diese Unternehmer sind halt nicht wirklich frei in ihren Entscheidungen,
sondern sie müssen halt das tun,
was vom Staat mehr oder weniger oder vom Regime dort vorgegeben wird.
Und ich kannte jemanden, der so um 2000 rum in Russland halt mit zehn anderen
Leuten ein Unternehmen,
einen großen Tanzclub gegründet hat, der sehr erfolgreich war.
Und ja, irgendwann dann...
Und nachdem das mit Putin losging, wurden sie zunehmend rausgedrängt.
Also erst kamen dann Leute auf sie zu, die dann gesagt haben,
sie müssen halt Propaganda machen in ihrem Club.
Für den Staat. Und nachdem sie sich da geweigert hatten, wurden sie dann Stück
für Stück rausgedrängt, verhaftet,
umgebracht oder sind ins Ausland geflohen.
Und das Ding wurde dann in regimetreue Hände übergeben. Und so sieht das in
vielen anderen Firmen auch aus.
Und das bedeutet halt, dass, ja,
wenn die Ansage kommt von oben, so produziert jetzt dies oder produziert jetzt
das oder die Preise werden dann teilweise dann auch festgesetzt,
nicht offiziell per Gesetz,
sondern alles auf irgendwelchen informellen Kanälen.
Und ja, das geht natürlich nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad gut und führt dann auch dazu,
dass viele Unternehmen einfach nicht funktionieren, weil sie eben nicht unternehmerisch geführt werden.
Und ja, das ist sozusagen die Situation.
Eine Menge dann an sicherlich auch Schwarzwirtschaft, die dann komplett ansteuern
und Staat vorbeigehen, Grauimporte,
die dann passieren, Schmuggel.
All das ist zur Normalität geworden in der Wirtschaft und auf der einen Seite hilft es schon,
dieses freie Unternehmertum natürlich ein bisschen schneller sich anzupassen,
aber in dem Sinne können die Eigentümer ihre Unternehmen nicht so führen,
wie es wirtschaftlich sinnvoll wäre.
Und das führt dann natürlich auf Dauer dazu, dass viele Dinge aufhören zu funktionieren,
aufhören produziert zu werden.
Ja, also die Unzufriedenheit steigt. Das merkt man auch, dass es jetzt,
es gab jetzt zum Beispiel so eine Protestaktion, wo dann auch echt mal viele
Russen irgendwie vom Kreml aufgetaucht sind mit irgendwelchen Forderungen.
Nichts davon bezog sich natürlich auf den Krieg, weil gefährlich,
aber so andere soziale Probleme, die dort thematisiert wurden,
das dürfte der Geheimdienst mit Interesse zur Kenntnis genommen haben.
Aber es zeigt sich schon, dass einfach hier so eine gewisse Unruhe auf jeden Fall schon losgeht.
Also von der Revolution sind wir glaube ich noch weit entfernt,
aber dieses wir halten einfach das Maul und der Staat kann machen, was er will, Ding,
das wird schwierig und zusammen mit der potenziellen Wintersituation,
wenn jetzt irgendwie auch noch Heizkraftwerke angegriffen werden von der Ukraine.
Das könnte Ärger geben, genauso wie die Tankstellensituation auch.
Dazu kommt noch, dass auch der Einzug von Wehrpflichtigen jetzt auf einen anderen
Modus umgestellt wurde.
Bisher war das in Russland immer so, dass es so einen jährlichen Stichtag gab.
Jetzt will man wohl so einen kontinuierlichen oder quartalsbasierten Einzug
vornehmen, um sozusagen noch mehr Wehrpflichtige aufzurufen,
die ja offiziell laut Verfassung nicht an der Front eingesetzt werden dürfen.
Aber wir wissen alle, das interessiert die Russen am Ende einen Scheiß.
Die Leute werden halt einfach unter Druck gesetzt, wenn sie erstmal da sind
und gezwungen, irgendwelche Verträge zu unterschreiben und dann landen die genauso
schnell an der Front oder zumindest sorgen sie irgendwie für eine Verstärkung
der aktiven Truppen auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Allein im vierten Quartal haben sie wohl vor, irgendwie weitere 135.000 zu rekrutieren.
Das ist alles so, Generalmobilmachung werden wir nicht sehen,
aber sie machen schon alles mögliche, um in irgendeiner Form ihre Kampfkraft
noch aufrecht zu erhalten und das wirkt jetzt nicht so, als ob sie da aus dem
Vollen schöpfen könnten.
Ja plus, ich sage mal laut Verfassung, gehören ja die besetzten Gebiete auch zu Russland.
Insofern ist das jetzt nicht unbedingt die Hürde, sondern ich glaube,
das ist auch dieser Wahnsinn, dass es auf der einen Seite diese Fiktion,
dass es alles Russland gibt, diese juristische Fiktion.
Aber auf der anderen Seite dann natürlich jeder genau weiß, dass es nicht wirklich Russland ist.
In dieser schizophrenen Situation befindet sich das russische Militär,
was jetzt so wehrpflichtige angeht.
Ja, aber der hybride Krieg gegen den Westen findet auch statt.
Vor ein paar Wochen gab es dann mal wieder einen Bericht, dass Drohnen auf das
Staatsgebiet Polens eingedrungen sind.
Und nicht wie das so früher war,
eine oder zwei, sondern sage und schreibe binnen einer Nacht 19 Drohnen.
Manche sind bis Warschau und auch, glaube ich, bis Danzig hinaus geflogen und
obwohl man irgendwie 19 Drohnen gesehen hat, konnte man sie nicht alle wiederfinden.
Eine ist, glaube ich, gestern irgendwo auf einer Wiese aufgetaucht.
Einige sind in ein Haus gestürzt in so ein Dach,
also es wurde glaube ich niemand getötet aber es gab zumindest Sachschaden und
das Hauptproblem war, dass Polen irgendwie nichts gemacht hat oder nichts machen
konnte das heißt sie sind nicht abgeschossen worden, sondern man hat das irgendwie alles beobachtet.
Damit ging es los, dann gab es den Überflug durch eine Militärmaschine weiß
jetzt nicht genau welche Art über so eine polnische,
Bohrinsel oder sowas, also irgendwie im Meer auf jeden Fall,
so ein Produktionsort und kurz da drauf gab es dann noch die Verletzung des estnischen,
Luftraums,
oder war es lettisch?
War es bei Riga? Ne, es war bei Tallinn, also in Estland.
Von gleich drei russischen Kampfflugzeugen,
und das Ding ist, es ist ja eigentlich zwischen Finnland Und Estland ist ja die Ostsee so eng,
dass eigentlich nach internationalem Seerecht da nur ein finnischer Bereich
ist und dann unmittelbar ein estnischer Bereich.
Also zwölf Kilometer sind das glaube ich von der Küste aus gesehen.
Das heißt, rein technisch gibt es da gar keine internationale Zone,
aber es gibt eine Vereinbarung,
mit der eben die Russen schon immer auf so einer klar definierten Linie dort
auch mit Flugzeugen fliegen dürfen und das ist dann quasi per Definition dann
ein internationaler Luftraum.
Den haben sie dann aber nach Süden hin deutlich und bewusst überschritten.
Die Flugzeuge haben sich auch nicht gemeldet auf, sie hatten glaube ich keine
Tracker an und das Ganze wirkte sehr ominös und die sind dann auch zwölf Minuten
in diesem falschen Luftraum verblieben.
Die sind jetzt nicht über Land geflogen, sondern das Ganze fand quasi über See
statt, aber naja, war auf jeden Fall eine Verletzung des Luftraums und die wussten
natürlich schon, was sie taten.
Und das Ganze wirkt natürlich sehr wie so ein Test der Russen.
Weil das waren jetzt auch keine Flugzeuge, mit denen man irgendwie,
also es war klar, dass von denen keine Gefahr ausging.
Warum? Weil es sich dabei um Mi-31 Flugzeuge handelt, das sind so Interceptor-Flugzeuge.
Abfangjäger.
Abfangjäger, die nur rein theoretisch in irgendeiner Variante auch noch eine
Bombe tragen könnten, die jetzt größeren Schaden ausrichten kann und es war
relativ klar von den Luftaufnahmen, die dann gemacht wurden.
Dass diese drei zumindest nicht getragen haben.
Darum ging es halt nicht, sondern es ging sozusagen mal wieder um so einen Test
und all das wirkt eben wie so ein Test.
Ein Test mit, wie reagiert ihr, wie schnell reagiert ihr, reagiert ihr überhaupt,
was habt ihr für Reaktionszeiten etc.
Also Russland guckt, was kann die NATO eigentlich.
Dann ging es weiter mit entsprechenden Drohnen, Sichtungen über dänischen Flughäfen.
Es gab jetzt glaube ich auch nochmal einen Vorfall in Norwegen und es gibt den
Verdacht, dass diese Drohnen, die dort zum Einsatz kamen,
dass die von Tankern der sogenannten Schattenflotte der Russen,
also diese nicht offiziellen Tanker, die halt irgendwie das Öl noch transportieren,
dass die, die da in der Ostsee kursieren, dass von denen aus diese Drohnen gestartet wurden.
Das hat Frankreich wohl so ernst genommen, dass sie jetzt einen Tanker sogar
festgesetzt haben. Da müssen wir mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Aber die eigentliche Frage, die natürlich jetzt über diesem Ganzen liegt,
ist, was tun wir jetzt dagegen?
Also die EU ist hier einfach klar, oder NATO vielmehr, ist jetzt hier klar herausgefordert worden,
so nach dem Motto, na, guck mal noch mal, was ihr macht, wenn wir hier irgendwie
Terror machen, abgesehen von diesem.
Generellen Terrorisieren von, na ihr werdet schon sehen, was ihr davon habt,
dass ihr jetzt hier irgendwie mitspielt, dieses Spiel ist natürlich da auch noch mit drin.
Ja, ich meine, was tun?
Natürlich flammte dann die Diskussion auf, ob man irgendwie dann vielleicht
die türkische Lösung favorisieren sollte.
Das war ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt schon wahrscheinlich so 10 Jahre her oder
nicht ganz, aber schon eine ganze Weile her,
wo die Türkei dann einen russischen Jet abgeschossen hat der,
ja nachdem Russland immer wieder im Prinzip in Syrien da gibt es so ein Zipfel
von So ein Zipfel Türkei,
der da reinragt und beim Bombardieren irgendwelcher Aufständischen ist Russland
dann eben statt um diesen Zipfel drumherum zu fliegen,
sind sie da einfach immer durchgeflogen.
Und die Türkei hat halt mehrfach protestiert und die Russen haben das halt weitergemacht
und daraufhin hat die Türkei dann einen russischen Jet abgeschossen und seitdem, ja,
respektieren die Russen den türkischen Luftraum.
So, haben zwar natürlich CETA und Mordio geschrien, aber am Ende des Tages, ja.
Ja, hat Erdogan auch echte Punkte gebracht innerhalb in der Türkei.
Die Aktion fanden sie dann doch alle sehr cool.
Und er hat sich auch drei Jahre lang bitten lassen, bevor er bereit war,
mit Putin die Sache dann sozusagen offiziell zu begraben und zu bedauern und so.
Aber das hat auf jeden Fall gesessen. Und das wäre natürlich jetzt für die NATO
theoretisch auch eine Option, wenn sie denn dazu überhaupt in der Lage sind.
Ja, wobei, wie gesagt, wenn man das jetzt mit der türkischen Situation vergleicht, damals,
da war es so, dass auch die Türken das nicht gleich nach dem ersten Mal,
sondern die haben zu der Maßnahme gegriffen,
nachdem die Russen das eben immer wieder und immer wieder gemacht haben.
Insofern würde ich jetzt schon mal nicht sagen, dass die NATO die Flugzeuge
hätte abschießen sollen oder so.
Und was die Drohnenüberflüge angeht, ist es halt eine gänzlich andere Situation natürlich, weil ja,
wird jetzt nicht mit Patriot-Raketen, also wenn man jetzt mit teuren Raketen
diese billigen Drohnen abschießt, das ist auch nicht das, was man regelmäßig machen sollte.
Das kann sich lohnen, wenn das Ziel, also wenn der Schaden,
den so eine russische Waffe machen kann, größer ist als der Preis von so einer Abwehrrakete,
kann sich das auch noch lohnen.
Aber grundsätzlich könnte man einerseits die Drohnen, wenn man entsprechende
Waffen hat, problemlos abschießen, ohne dass das zu irgendeiner Eskalation führt.
Aber mit den Kampfflugzeugen, das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Situation.
Und die politische Dimension des Ganzen erinnert mich so an die ersten sechs
Monate des Krieges nach der Invasion.
Hatten wir auch viel diskutiert, dass Russland oder Putin gerne hätte,
dass die NATO eingreift aus innenpolitischen Gründen.
Und ja, um dann sagen zu können, natürlich, wir werden von der NATO angegriffen
und müssen deshalb mobilisieren.
Das heißt, dass das sozusagen ein Play war damals oder ein Wunsch,
die NATO zu involvieren.
Und gut, propagandamäßig redet Russland sowieso dagegen, die ganze Zeit gegen
die NATO zu kämpfen, weil die Ukraine,
diese kleine, unbedeutende Ukraine, ist undenkbar, dass die alleine jetzt irgendwie
Russland standhalten würde.
Deswegen muss das so sein, dass
Russland eigentlich gegen die NATO und eigentlich gegen Amerika kämpft.
Aber natürlich dieses Narrativ macht natürlich angesichts Trump und was Trump
an Chaos veranstaltet hat, macht natürlich immer weniger Sinn.
Und Trump hat glaube ich auch mit seinem chaotischen Verhalten auch zu einem
Haufen Problemen für Putin geführt,
was so die russische Politik angeht.
Also auch Trumps Säen von Chaos ist auch an Russland und an Putin nicht spurlos
oder folgenlos vorbei gegangen.
Und wie gesagt, vor dem Hintergrund, ja, hatte ich den Eindruck,
neben, also dass diese Angriffe, diese Provokationen,
außer dass sie vielleicht auch Zwietracht in der NATO sehen sollten und gewisse
Eskalationsgefahren heraufbeschwören sollten.
Und möglicherweise tatsächlich die NATO dazu zu bringen,
tatsächlich etwas zu tun, was Putin dann innenpolitisch nutzen kann,
um dann die Russen zu motivieren.
Weil auf der anderen Seite wird in Russland natürlich der Krieg immer unpopulärer.
Und insofern wäre jetzt so eine Eskalation etwas, was Putin durchaus in die Hände spielen könnte.
Sodass ich denke, was jetzt diese Überflüge angeht, ist erstmal cool zu bleiben, tatsächlich die,
Die richtige Variante, was jetzt aber die Drohnenüberflüge angeht, sowohl die Drohnen,
die jetzt über die Ukraine nach Polen eingedrungen sind, als auch diese anderen Belästigungsdrohnen,
die da jetzt über westlichen Städten und in der Nähe von Flughäfen kreisen.
Da, finde ich, sollte man drastischer reagieren.
Gut, teilweise wurde ja auch drastisch reagiert.
Ich glaube, über Dänemark gilt jetzt eine Woche absolutes Drohnenflugverbot.
Also auch Privatpersonen dürfen keine Drohnen aufsteigen lassen und ähnliche Dinge.
Aber ja, da bin ich der Meinung, dass der Westen durchaus, was Drohnen angeht, zusehen sollte.
Und ich glaube, das passiert auch, sollte halt einfach Drohnen abschießen,
die von Russland kommen, wie auch immer man das bewerkstelligen möchte.
Und aus meiner Sicht die nächste Eskalationsstufe tatsächlich vom Westen aus
wäre, aktiv dabei zu helfen,
den ukrainischen Luftraum zu verteidigen.
Ja, das, finde ich, wäre eine Maßnahme, wo man Russland über die Stränge schlägt,
diese durchaus ergreifen sollte und dann auch letztlich mit NATO-Kampfflugzeugen
über der Ukraine zu operieren.
Ja, das ist halt jetzt so die generelle politische Frage.
Was sollte der Westen jetzt tun? Und der Westen ist jetzt im Wesentlichen Europa,
weil USA haben klar gemacht, dass sie irgendwie zwar ganz gerne Geld verdienen
mit diesem Krieg, aber ansonsten nicht groß mitmachen wollen.
Auch wenn sich jetzt so ein bisschen die Meinung bei Trump gerade mal wieder
in die eine Richtung streckt,
dass die Ukraine ja jetzt doch angeblich das Land zurückerobern könnte und dass
man irgendwie auch russische Flugzeuge abschießen kann.
Das sind ja so Äußerungen, die getätigt wurden zur größten Überraschung von
allen Beteiligten und Unbeteiligten, die zumindest jetzt, sagen wir mal,
es Leuten einfacher macht in den USA, die pro-ukrainisch unterwegs sind.
Da gibt es ja eine Menge und die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung ist es eh.
Wieder Aktivitäten zu entwickeln, weil sich der Magerblock da nicht direkt gegen
Wert unmittelbar wehrt, wenn Trump sagt, das geht schon.
Trotzdem muss halt Europa jetzt irgendwie zu sich selber finden und davon sind
wir glaube ich noch ziemlich weit entfernt also so eine gemeinsame europäische Außen- oder,
Verteidigungspolitik, davon
ist noch nicht so richtig was zu merken klar, ist ja auch kein Wunder,
gerade wenn man jetzt irgendwie so Gestalten wie Orban und Vizo noch an der
Backe hat, aber auch ein Spanien oder so ist da sicherlich anders aufgestellt
als sagen wir mal jetzt Polen.
Trotz alledem brauchst du halt jetzt mal eine Strategie und ich habe überhaupt
so den Eindruck, dass jetzt irgendwie nach drei Jahren,
mehr als drei Jahren, dass wir jetzt an so einen Punkt kommen,
ich erinnere mich noch, als wir mit dieser Serie angefangen haben, Pavel also als wir,
überhaupt ich meine, es kann auch sein, dass es in der ersten Sendung war oder
eine der ersten Sendungen auf jeden Fall, als wir so darüber gesprochen haben,
okay, was kann Europa jetzt tun und hast du gesagt,
Ja, beim Zweiten Weltkrieg hat das ja auch ein paar Jahre gedauert,
bis alle bereit waren, hier in irgendeiner Form einzugreifen.
Man hat halt irgendwie erstmal die Nazis so ein strenges Du-Du-Du entgegengeworfen,
hat dann aber gemerkt, dass diese ganze Appeasement-Politik halt komplett nach
hinten losgegangen ist, dass das Problem immer größer wird.
Irgendwann haben die Deutschen halt auch angefangen, irgendwelche amerikanischen Schiffe zu versenken.
Und irgendwann ist es dann halt politisch so weit eskaliert,
dass klar war, okay, jetzt gehen wir hier mal dagegen vor, weil das kann jetzt
so nicht immer weitergehen.
Und ich frage mich halt, wann wir mit Europa an diesem Punkt angekommen sein
werden, dass auch hier klar wird, das wird für uns hier einfach alles nur noch
teuer und weiter bedrohlich.
Wir müssen jetzt einfach mal hier gegen vorgehen.
Alle, die, denke ich, diesen Krieg und das, was sich in den letzten dreieinhalb
Jahren so abgespielt hat,
regelmäßig und enger begleiten, sind sich, glaube ich, mehr oder weniger einig
darin, dass von Russland, von Putin, keine politische Lösung zu erwarten ist.
Es wird keine Verhandlungen geben über einen Frieden.
Es wird keinen Rückzug, einen freiwilligen Rückzug geben.
Es gibt da auch keine konkreten Forderungen, die man auch nur irgendwie erfüllen
könnte, weil die einzige Forderung, die Russland hat, ist, dass die Ukraine sterben muss.
Und es ist nicht verhandelbar und dieses, wir müssen uns da raushalten oder
das ist nicht unser Krieg und solche Formulierungen, die halt immer noch auf
den Tisch geworfen werden von manchen, da kann ich nur sagen,
Ja, das ist eine schöne Wunschvorstellung, dass das nicht unser Krieg ist.
Es ist eine schöne Wunschvorstellung, sich so einen allgemeinen Frieden zu wünschen.
Es ist auch eine schöne Wunschvorstellung, von so einem grundsätzlichen Pazifismus
auszugehen, in dem alle sich erstmal zurückhalten und wenn keiner mit irgendwas
anfängt, dann wird schon alles gut werden.
Und alle sind nicht sofort beleidigt, wenn dann doch mal einer kurz ausrutscht
und wenn man dann nur friedlich bleibt, dann werden schon alle anderen friedlich werden.
Das sind alles interessante Überlegungen.
Allerdings gehen die einfach komplett an der russischen Realität vorbei.
So verhält sich dieses Land nicht, so verhält sich Putin nicht.
Und es ist auch nicht nur Putin, sondern es ist halt mittlerweile eine auf dramatische
Art und Weise hirngewaschene Gesellschaft,
die keine richtigen Informationen hat, die auch in so einem super kranken Nationalismus
feststeckt, wie wir das halt in Deutschland auch gehabt haben und wie das jetzt
auch teilweise in den USA zu sehen ist.
Immer diese Illusion, man sei ja am eigenen Ort, das wäre ja immer das Geilste
und alles andere ist halt irgendwie scheiße.
Und wenn nur wir in Anführungsstrichen überall herrschen, dann wird ja alles gut werden.
Das ist ja auch so ein russisches Bild, sodass Russland ja den Frieden über die Welt bringt.
Die NATO ist ja der eigentliche Aggressor. Also diese komplette Verdrehung von
Tatsachen, die sich relativ einfach überprüfen lassen, das findet...
Das findet einfach nicht statt. Es gibt diesen Frieden nicht.
Friedensverhandlungen mit Russland sind pointless, weil es gibt nichts,
worüber die mit sich verhandeln lassen.
Es gibt keine irgendwie akzeptablen Forderungen der Russen, die man erfüllen
könnte, weil die Vernichtung der Ukraine, die Einverleibung der ukrainischen
Gebiete, das ist nicht nur so.
Entwaffnung der ukrainischen Bevölkerung.
Ja, es ist alles aus idealistischen schon nicht akzeptabel. Es ist praktisch
einfach auch, die Ukraine würde dem sowieso nie zustimmen können.
Und das sind auch alles überhaupt gar keine legitimen Forderungen.
Die einzige legitime Forderung ist, Russland soll sich gefälligst komplett wieder
zurückziehen auf die Position, wie es vor 2014 war und gut ist.
Und danach reden wir über 50 Jahre Reparationszahlung. Das ist eigentlich das einzige Ende.
Nur, das wird Russland halt selber nicht machen.
Da ist halt Russland nicht anders als Nazi-Deutschland.
Und deswegen ist es halt erforderlich, dass man den Russen klar auf C zeigt, ihr habt keine Chance.
Das wird für euch viel zu teuer. Das wird euch alles sehr wehtun,
wenn ihr diesen Weg weiterverfolgt.
Und an der Stelle versteht Russland leider nur eine Sprache,
nämlich die militärische Sprache.
Das ist bedauernswert.
Ich wünsche mir das auch nicht, aber ich sehe keinen anderen Weg.
Also erstmal habe ich auch noch von keinem anderen Weg gehört,
der so geäußert wird, der auch nur irgendwie realistisch ist.
Und eigentlich gibt es generell relativ wenig Vorschläge über einen Weg,
sondern es wird eigentlich von vielen, die jetzt gegen eine stärkere Unterstützung der Ukraine sind,
eigentlich immer nur gesagt, was sie gerne nicht machen würden,
aber nicht was sie tun möchten, um wirklich hier in irgendeiner Form zu einer
Lösung des Konfliktes beizutragen.
Ich meine, gut, was ja jetzt auf dem Plan stand oder was Trump ja propagiert
hat, war quasi ein einfrierendes Konflikt.
So, das war ja, dass man halt Waffenstillstand und dann im Prinzip einfach nur
aufhört, sich gegenseitig umzubringen.
Aber ansonsten erstmal alles so bleibt mehr oder weniger wie es ist.
Das hat Trump ja mehr oder weniger den Russen angeboten als Kompromiss.
Aber die Russen sind darauf zum Glück nicht eingegangen,
weil das wahrscheinlich ein Problem dargestellt hätte für die Ukraine,
weil in dem Moment dann wahrscheinlich die Unterstützung für die Ukraine aus
dem Westen dann irgendwie nachgelassen hätte.
Wobei dann eben auch klar war.
Dass man dann irgendwelche Garantien, also dass halt dann Truppen,
ausländische Truppen dann dort, also Friedenstruppen, dann den Waffenstillstand
hätten absichern sollen.
Wobei Putin dann die Idee hatte, klar machen wir das,
sozusagen chinesische und koreanische Truppen können dann dort den Frieden sichern,
während auf NATO-Seite dann diese neue Koalition der Willigen,
wo dann verschiedene Länder gesagt haben, Ja,
wie eben auch, ich glaube, Frankreich und UK waren dabei und ja,
andere kleinere Länder, die auch gesagt haben, ja klar, wir sind dabei,
wir schicken Truppen.
Wir sind bereit, Friedenstruppen zu schicken, um dann einen Waffenstillstand zu stabilisieren.
Aber das ist natürlich ein absolutes No-Go wiederum für die Russen.
Nach dem Motto, wie, dann haben wir jetzt plötzlich dann doch,
zwar ist dann Ukraine zwar kein
NATO-Mitglied, hat aber dann jede Menge NATO-Friedenstruppen dann dort.
Das wollen die Russen natürlich wiederum überhaupt nicht haben oder überhaupt
nicht bereit, dazu in die Richtung zu gehen.
Insofern, ja, es gibt im Moment einfach keine Grundlage, keine auch nur irgendwie
geartete erreichbare Schnittmenge an Kompromiss oder so.
Ja, weshalb das Einzige, was man denn jetzt machen kann, ist,
so auf Russland einzuwirken, um halt kompromissfähiger zu werden,
weil Kraine ja im Prinzip ihre Bereitschaft erklärt hat zu einem Einfrieren des Konflikts.
Auch wenn das nicht gut gewesen wäre aber ja.
Insofern ich weiß auch noch ich hatte ganz am Anfang,
auch als wir angefangen haben über die Ukraine zu reden die Frage ja wie lange
geht das denn noch und ich hatte dann irgendwas von 10 Jahren in den Raum geworfen,
ich hoffe nicht dass es so lange dauern wird, aber ja,
wir sind jetzt in Jahr vier, oder?
Also ich würde schon sagen, das ist ein bisschen schwierig,
aber was wir jetzt in dieser Sendung auch wieder geschildert haben,
also die Verschärfung der wirtschaftlichen Situation Russlands,
das wird nicht besser werden. Und das ist jetzt schon ziemlich schlimm.
Die Angreife auf die Infrastruktur, wenn es jetzt auch noch die Kraftwerke trifft
und die Ukraine auch nur halbwegs so erfolgreich ist,
damit wie jetzt mit den Raffinerien, dann könnte es sehr schnell sehr bedrohlich werden.
Vor allem, weil es halt dann auch die Bevölkerung stärker betrifft.
Und wir sehen das jetzt schon mit diesen Tankstellen. Bisher konnte man immer
alles so ignorieren. Ja, Krieg, das ist da irgendwo in der Ukraine.
Ganz weit weg kann ich nichts mit zu tun. Mein Leben geht irgendwie normal weiter.
Ja, es sind zwei, drei aus meinem Umfeld verschwunden.
Aber das betrifft mich ja nicht. Also bisher haben sich die Russen das irgendwie
schön geredet. Und das wird jetzt nicht mehr so ohne weiteres funktionieren.
Militärisch, die Russen sind zwar sehr kreativ auch da drin,
irgendwie immer wieder neue Ansätze zu finden, aber die Verluste sind halt extrem hoch.
Auch die Panzerreserven sind im Prinzip, glaube ich, in diesem Jahr dürften
wir jetzt so langsam auf Null gekommen sein.
Also sie bauen vielleicht ein paar, aber nicht ansatzweise so viele, wie sie bräuchten.
Und der gesamte militärische Produktionskomplex hat vor allem das Problem,
dass sie produzieren auch wirklich nur noch für den unmittelbaren Verbrauch.
Es gibt in dem Sinne keinen Export mehr. Also auch die Waffenproduktion,
die Waffenindustrie war ja für Russland eine weitere wichtige,
nicht nur wirtschaftliche Einnahme, sondern auch für ihren Anspruch einer Weltbedeutung.
In dem Moment, wo du andere in deine Waffensysteme mit einbeziehst,
Indien etc., stellst du ja da sozusagen auch so eine politische Connection her.
Ja, das dürfte jetzt auch nicht mehr so stattfinden und ich würde mir durchaus
vorstellen, dass wir da auch bald China sehen in dem Bereich,
die derzeit glaube ich, was so Exporte betrifft, noch nicht so weit vorne sind,
aber sicherlich bald besser aufgestellt sind als die Russen an der Stelle.
Vor allem, weil sie keinen Krieg führen noch und ja.
Was ich sagen will ist es macht auf mich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob wir so langsam.
Am Anfang vom Ende ankommen. Also dass wir jetzt so in eine Phase übergehen,
von der man vielleicht in der Zukunft sagen kann,
da hat sich das jetzt abgezeichnet, weil es ist derzeit nicht absehbar,
wie sich jetzt Russland noch nennenswert verstärken kann, um in irgendeiner
Form auf dem Schlachtfeld noch größere Erfolge zu erzielen.
Sie können natürlich jetzt weiterhin diesen Modus beibehalten und unter enormen
Verlusten arbeiten, aber es wird sie wirtschaftlich jetzt demnächst stark auf
die Füße fallen, es wird für sehr viel mehr Unruhe im Land sorgen und wir wissen alle,
die Dinge gehen so lange unbemerkt voran, bis es sich auf einmal schlagartig ändert.
Und dieser Punkt kann durchaus bald erreicht sein.
Bald im Sinne von vielleicht nicht dieses Jahr, vielleicht aber schon nächstes
Jahr, dass sich das abzeichnet. Da wird jetzt relativ viel von diesem Winterverlauf
und den weiteren Kampagnen abhängen.
Aber ich denke, dass die Ukraine in zunehmendem Maße einen technologischen Vorsprung sich erarbeitet.
Also was auch immer die Russen jetzt nachziehen, die Ukraine ist da einfach
sehr viel kreativer unterwegs und profitiert natürlich auch von der Kooperation
mit europäischen Rüstungsunternehmen, Rheinmetall, Bautafabriken etc.
Es gibt viele Kooperationen mit den Engländern, mit den Deutschen.
Ich glaube auch mit Italienern, auf jeden Fall entstehen da Verbindungen,
wenn jetzt irgendwie die Schweden da noch mit reinkommen, die Gripen auch noch als System bringen.
Also irgendwann wird die Ukraine zwangsläufig auch eine gewisse militärische
Stärke haben und ist jetzt im Prinzip schon die beste Armee in Europa.
Und wir müssen uns glaube ich im Westen klar machen, dass die Ukraine ist derzeit
die Schutzmacht Europas.
Die USA hat diese Rolle aufgegeben, hat gesagt, uns auch egal,
ihr seid alle doof und riecht nach Lulu.
Wir machen jetzt hier ein bisschen unseren Mini-Faschismus und wir haben euch nicht mehr lieb.
Und Europa so, oh Gott.
Und wer beschützt uns denn jetzt sozusagen vor Gefahr? Die Gefahr ist klar,
die Gefahr ist Russland. Die fliegen Drohnen über uns.
Es gibt einen permanenten Propagandakrieg, der angefacht wird,
um so Player wie die AfD zu unterstützen oder generell einfach den politischen
Diskurs auseinanderzureißen.
Das findet ja schon seit vielen Jahren statt und das wird immer schlimmer.
Und es gibt einfach diese Gefahr durch Russland, das ist offensichtlich.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit, dass wir uns gegen Russland derzeit verteidigen
können, ist die Tatsache, dass die Ukraine für uns kämpft.
Und niemand sonst. Und deswegen gilt es halt, die Ukraine nicht nur zu unterstützen
bei diesem Kampf, sondern es gilt eigentlich diesen Kampf gemeinsam zu führen.
Also so zumindest darüber nachzudenken. Das heißt nicht unbedingt,
dass jetzt morgen deutsche Truppen gen Osten ziehen, das ist nicht unbedingt das, was ich sage,
aber es gäbe so viele Möglichkeiten, die Ukraine zu entlasten,
die derzeit nicht gemacht werden,
also von einer Luftraumsicherung im Westen der Ukraine zum Beispiel,
also jenseits der Frontlinien.
Warum sind da nicht europäische Kräfte im Einsatz?
Logistischer Support innerhalb der Ukraine würde die Ukraine enorm entlasten.
Komplette Beschlagnahmung der russischen Gelder, die hier beschlagnahmt wurden
und Bereitstellung dieser 300 Milliarden US-Dollar, damit die Ukraine damit
einfach den Kampf fortsetzen kann.
Es gibt so viele Dinge, wo derzeit kein Land oder zumindest die EU als Ganzes
oder Europa als Ganzes, nehmen wir mal die Briten noch mit rein,
bereit wären, jetzt über das Stückchen zu springen und zu sagen,
okay, alles klar, jetzt sind wir auch in diesem Krieg.
Dabei ist es vollkommen offensichtlich, dass dieser Krieg da ist,
existiert und gegen uns gerichtet ist.
Und das Tragische ist,
Wir muten der Ukraine auch unglaublich viel zu.
Ja, furchtbar.
Und die Ukraine steht natürlich, wir haben jetzt viel über Russland geredet,
wie sich dort die Situation verschlechtert oder verschlimmert,
aber in der Ukraine ist die Situation halt auch nicht gut.
So, die Leute leiden halt auch massiv.
Sowohl die Soldaten an der Front, Die sind wahrscheinlich auch viele ganz schön
durch nach so viel Krieg und natürlich diese nächtlichen Angriffe,
die die Bevölkerung terrorisieren und auch Infrastruktur zerstören und so,
das ist nicht hilfreich.
Das ist nicht gut.
Ich mache mir einfach ein bisschen Sorgen, dass wir eventuell der Ukraine zu viel zumuten könnten.
Und ich meine, im Moment sieht es so aus, als würde sie ja nach wie vor ganz, ganz gut widerstehen.
Aber wie du schon richtig sagtest.
Ein Zusammenbruch deutet sich nicht unbedingt langfristig vorher an,
sondern es kommt halt dann plötzlich irgendwann.
Und ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Ukraine jetzt komplett zusammenbricht oder so,
ist glücklicherweise nicht zu erwarten, weil sie halt nicht so isoliert ist wie Russland.
Aber auch bei Russland ist es auch nicht zu erwarten, dass die jetzt irgendwann
in nächster Nähe zusammenbrechen,
wobei es dort in Russland eher die Bevölkerung unterstützt diesen Krieg mehrheitlich nicht.
Es gibt keine Kriegsbegeisterung in Russland bisher.
Während in der Ukraine ist es ein Überlebenskampf.
Das heißt, die Motivation ist dort in der Ukraine auch eine andere und macht
es halt deswegen wahrscheinlich nicht.
Erträglicher oder ja, dass das Leid hilft halt besser,
dass das Leid zu ertragen, als es möglicherweise dann in Russland der Fall sein
dürfte, wenn größere Teile der Bevölkerung plötzlich betroffen sind,
massiv betroffen sind von Stromausfällen und Spritknappheit.
Also könnte sein, dass die Russen da, obwohl sie bekannt sind,
ja für ihre Leidensfähigkeit dann einfach dann doch nicht so motiviert,
sich als doch nicht so motiviert erweisen könnten.
Wie man vielfach glaubt.
Aber wir wissen es einfach nicht und wir sollten uns auf keinen Fall zurücklehnen und sagen,
die Ukraine wird es schon richten für uns, sondern das ist gefährlich,
was wir machen im Moment.
Und so dieses, ja, gucken wir mal, machen so viel wie unbedingt nötig, aber nicht mehr.
Und so, das ist eine gefährliche Strategie.
Auf der anderen Seite hoffe ich, in der Vergangenheit gab es ja jetzt bestimmte Weichenstellungen,
dass Geld in Produktionsaufbau und Infrastruktur und Rüstungsproduktion investiert
wurde oder werden sollte und neuen Fabriken und so weiter.
Die müssten natürlich irgendwann jetzt auch mal vielleicht, sollten eigentlich
irgendwann mal auch jetzt sichtbar werden, diese Anstrengungen,
dass da tatsächlich vielleicht irgendwann wir an dem Punkt sind,
dass man die Ukraine dann mit Material überhäufen kann.
Das ist ja das, was, wie die Amerikaner geholfen haben, dann den Zweiten Weltkrieg zu gewinnen,
in dem einfach massiv auf Rüstungsproduktion umgestellt wurde und Flugzeuge
zu Hunderttausenden produziert wurden.
Wir reden jetzt von, ich sage mal, Hunderten von Flugzeugen und gut,
das war jetzt auch andere Technik und so, aber die Dimension,
wenn man wirklich industrielle Produktion auf Kriegsproduktion ausrichtet.
Da könnten wir, sind wir wahrscheinlich noch zwei Größenordnungen drüber von entfernt.
Also man könnte wahrscheinlich die Rüstungsproduktion verhundertfachen, wenn man wollte.
Aber es passiert natürlich nicht, weil auch die Situation für uns nicht so dramatisch
zu sein scheint. Es wirkt sich ja nur ein bisschen auf die Preise aus bei uns.
Aber ansonsten fallen bei uns keine Bomben.
Plus ein bisschen russische Sabotage hier und da, brennt mal eine Rüstungsfabrik
bei uns oder wird mal eine Stromversorgung abgefackelt oder eine Pipeline gesprengt.
Aber ansonsten sind wir in unserem Alltag weitgehend unberührt von dem Konflikt.
Und das führt dann natürlich wieder dazu, dass die Dringlichkeit nicht so stark zu sein scheint.
Ja, ich denke an der Stelle können wir es dann auch zu Ende bringen, hier dieses Update.
Es gibt jetzt natürlich noch tausend Kleinigkeiten, die man auch noch erwähnen
kann, aber für das Big Picture sollte das erstmal reichen.
Ja, wir sagen wieder vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Ich hoffe, dass euch unsere Zusammenfassung auch weiterhin etwas geben und wir
werden natürlich auch weiterhin hier die Kanäle,
verfolgen und hoffen natürlich, dass es besser wird und es gibt eigentlich genug
Anlass zu glauben, dass wir dazu in der Lage sind, jetzt müssen wir das einfach nur auch umsetzen.
Ja, macht's gut, haltet die Ohren steif.
Genau, und dann hören wir uns wieder bald.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.